jaillira sur mon écran le chat jaillit
même si j'aime être un petit chat
fenêtres et s'avoue peuvent bien vas-y
met toi bien thamond partage d'écran tu
es tranquille on a guéri guerrieri
j'attends ce triple gastro day c'est au
coach de courtois je sais pas c'est
alors à l'éthique comme blague est
devenu droit la force en fait non mais
c'est ça donne envie de faire rire il
dirige pour sa part déjà quoi tout en
appelant le souffle et boum
je ne parlais pas ils les parakois fins
et gèrent ils ont lancé le truc quand
artemiev s'élever quoi il s'est barré
pas de chance défaite par forfait
essayez revenu mensuel
oui parce que trois c4 g3 verte à mieux
il sait de quel dégoûté qui ont demandé
d'aller replacer sa caméra tient à
replacer ta caméra derrière on voit pas
bien
bon bah du coup tu passes ton temps
commençait d'ailleurs d'accord les 20
pions serait beau quoiqu'il le troll
deux tiers à la dégager
n'empêche on rigole mais au dans
certains sports comme le foot ou quoi ça
arrive qu'il ya vrai que l'arbitrage ou
quoi quand tu me lis quoi à ce terrible
alors appareils hadji cully qui demande
sa lucas petite question j'ai pris un
abonnement gold sur che ce cas mais je
n'ai pas compris à quoi j'ai totalement
axé avec les leçons j'ai que le son du
débutant ou tout je crois que t'as pas
accès à toutes les leçons avec le or je
croyais avoir monté en puissance ça
ouais ce qui est sûr c'est que pour
avoir tes vidéos par exemple pour les
pions double ou quoi je crois que c'est
le diamant mais du coup le diamant est
plus précieux que l'or quoi mais je
pense en réalité que c'est le cas
d'ailleurs le diamant le diamant et en
étant une pierre qui peut aussi servir à
faire beaucoup de choses au delà de l'or
d'astrée solidum c'est bien peu après
pas plus solide
il n'y a pas plus solide donc fab cette
position alors écoute c'est un genre de
gambie dames avec g6 avec tap ces deux
puits g6 du coup webagoo de vos toiles
filantes de la slave ou
il a joué dans le dos 4e coup donc pour
l'idée c'est de défendre tombe sur ces 4
peut paraître 4 à jour et donc c'est
pour ça que lire il a joué avec g6 pour
pouvoir permettre foot cases blanches de
venir à 1,5
si vous n'êtes pas été possible de base
parce que la dame aurait mangé le fou et
donc cela permit de faire re bouger
cette dame et de la déloger de la gaule
est juste excuse moi je te coupe pour
répondre à jumper 59 youtube dit c'est
utile c'est thabo payant ou même
indispensable franchement c'est un
excellent produit lab l'abonnement
l'abonnement chess comme après c'est pas
indispensable tu peux tu peux vivre sans
tu peux progresser aux échecs sans c'est
juste ça va te permettre d'avoir accès à
énormément de contenu et de cours pour
un prix quand même assez assez ridicule
fab je t'ai pas vu les toits que c'est
votre cher c'est ça peut être augmenté à
99 dollars par an mais tu vois pour
avoir accès à toutes les vidéos
l'analyse d'ordi les leçons les puzzles
rush fatal pas juste ou en fait à cet
abonnement tâte tout ce dont on a besoin
en fait un truc en plus si les prix
restent en dollars maintenant que l'euro
est monté par rapport c'est peut-être le
bon moment pour dire ah tiens je suis
une bonne affaire la stratégie
grand-angle la stratégie web à la art
est entré ce ratage là bas je suis très
stratège j'attends la chute de l'or pour
m'abonner à des trucs comme quoi ils
disent que ses 89 ans et 89 dollars ou
euros en fait 80 euros franchement 89
euros honnêtement pour tous les produits
qui à l'intérieur
c'est ça vaut le coup après ça dépend de
vos budgets c'est pendant tout un chacun
à ses blessures
si pour toi c'est pas énormément
d'argent que tu es déjà abonnés à
netflix je sais pas quoi et d'autres et
d'autres services en ligne 89 euros pour
tous les produits réuni dessus c'est
très bon marché tata jacques pin qui l'a
pris pour les analyser les problèmes
illimité ça c'est que tu as beaucoup de
produits différents en fait qui sont
dedans
vingt ans beaucoup de choses ouais
chacun pourrait trouver son bonheur
après bien sûr voilà comme des écueils
ça dépend voilà déjà suffisament budget
à mettre dedans quitte en plus consacré
aux échecs et vos objectifs
tu sais juste jouer pour le fun faire de
trois parties par jour ça sert à rien si
vous envie d'essayer de progresser
d'apprendre des thèmes stratégiques des
petites leçons des choses comme ça ça
peut être très cool oui après le truc
ultime c'est les cours particuliers etc
alors c'est encore un autre budget vous
progresser encore plus d'ailleurs fatwa
qui a beaucoup d'élèves
je crois que même beaucoup d'élèves qui
font les deux d'ailleurs noms qui font
particulier et abat d'un diamant pas en
fait on va dire enfin ce que je crois
vraiment on sait que le plus important
pour être pour progresser c'est
travailler soi même donc tout ce qu'on
va comprendre par soi même c'est
important et pas juste suivent des cours
passivement après balata du cours
particuliers pour poser des questions
précises et aborder des thèmes qu'on a
du mal à résoudre soi même donc les
trucs sont un peu floues un peu
compliqué ou s'il constatait un petit
répertoire dames et ça j'aime pas trop
je me retrouve mal à chaque fois comment
je peux pas reste rude et là ça sert
vraiment mais juste prendre même cinq
heures par semaine si vous avez beau
budget est rien faire à côté c'est moins
bien que celui qui prendra une heure
tous les quinze jours mais qui dans son
coin sera retravaillé analyser un peu et
voilà ça c'est pour ça que je dis que le
combo ultime c'est et l'abonnement et
les coursayres tu as bossé l'afrique
avec l'abonnement tu vas voir les cours
vidéo
donc tu as bossé par toi même et après
tu voir le prof qui va venir une fois ou
deux fois dans la semaine pour
t'expliquer ce que tu as mal compris ou
te réexpliqué où aller plus loin ou
approfondir la voilà ça c'est le truc
ultime après pour ceux qui ont un budget
encore supérieur mais j'ai envie de dire
nous allons devoir finalement toi tu
prends des cours de tennis moi aussi
femmes
telli c'est dur quand tes sales quoi
à aider seul tenant même truc tu as
quelqu'un de concepts corriger ton
mouvement bateau tueur pratiques tu va
refaire le combattre recorrigé puis il
ya force de répétition tu va intégrer à
dire la plus simple mais il ya aussi
ajustement des gens qui ont parlé dans
le chat est aussi la chaîne la chaîne
bitstream sur youtube lassé des vidéos
gratuites qui est aussi bien donc vous
avez enfin bref si vous avez tout ça
vous avez vraiment le combo ultime vous
avez tout en fait reste plus qu'à
travailler
c'est le plus cher ou pas d'ailleurs un
temps pee wee je prends tout mais je ne
t'ai pas vraiment travailler ce qu'on
fait tous au final non ouais et il me
fasse cadeau il suffit pas d'étudier
mais je vois aussi des parties entières
oui oui bah c'est la blessure peut tout
faire
mais d'où l'intérêt d'un truc comme
thiès comme avec parce qu'en fait tu
écoutes à la zone de jeu tu peux
réanalyse était parti avec l'ordinateur
enfin du coup tu as un peu tout cas pas
les courtes à la fin tu fais les cours à
côté tu tu as vraiment où vous avez un
peu tous les filons oui après c'est une
question de budget terrible comme prévu
notre petit oui les cours on demande toi
tu prends quoi 65 70 pour une heure
ouais par la mare par la 65 70 va pas se
dépenser un cours comme ça c'est long
terme la fréquence des choses comme ça
on ne peut pas lâcher d'infos bon ok 65
ça va donc donc ok on a eu des infos
qu'on voulait début de match fab
complètement a pas parlé de la partie
mais on voit bien sur l'échiquier pions
plus pour pour le sibérien le sibérien
qui met tout de suite la pression sur
sur guy un bail
il envoie une attaque de glace direct
ouais là c'est compliqué compliqué pour
guy qui a peut-être se prendre un petit
os 4 un petit 4 des 5 pour avancer le
centre c'est quelqu'un très mal beaucoup
de ces perdants mais bon encore vous
finir mais en plus il est bien autant
artemiev malgré malgré son retard au
début pour brancher la caméra
donc il en contrôle ouais c'est pas
suffi chez 4 se fait que 4 et a fait g4
tout est bien après
même le cavalier peut ne pas ressortir
d'air le problème c'est que le fouette 5
on sait pas trop comment faire si on
vend aussi s'il ya des cinq puis la
pitié donc va remettre je peux en b1
quoi c'est pas un peu artificielle comme
enfin pas trop commence à tenir tout ça
c'est très bien ça on aurait bien aimé
faire tourner a malheureusement la tour
doit défendre le fossé 7 sinon tour d'un
an soit ce serait nickel on nous a
calqué vallier s'il bouge on prendra le
foot mais mais ça nous pousse à nous
rapporterait donc vaut mieux pas le
faire et à tombe plus tard et sa défense
sur rêve d'europe
je pensais aussi sous b 4 n'écoutez pas
ce qu'il veut pas commencer par des cinq
mois sur les dessins qui aura fois fou
g7 pour ces six à oui vu oui il veut
peut-être fois six tours à 7 qui
essaient huit tours à huit roues
bessette
c'est sympa pour muret d'autres sources
c'est marrant là on voit vraiment ce
parti on voit vraiment l'importance
d'harmoniser puis à cela il ya des
petits groupes chez les noirs n va on
est là le moi je suis là bas ils sont
pas en harmonie
mais pas du tout d'ailleurs assez rare
gérard une pêche aussi mal organisé
c'était un f4 il prépare 4 peut-être il
prépare aussi tour ses huit fois justice
matt assez terrible tu prépares de
partout tu as du mal à voir ce qu'ils ne
menacent pas en fait c'est bien
maintenant peut-être eu quatre bébés 3
vous et 4 basta terrible
non être très bonne partie pour
l'instant duarte est requis mais
directement les points sur les i voici
le vainqueur du match
magnus carlsen et on disait qu artemiev
pouvait être un joueur qui gênent même
le champion du monde par tdf c'est pas
un cadeau
non non non ce paquet de l'étude il est
très bon et donc innover au score ils se
sont petit à 6 alors vaut mieux pas
jouer des 4 c'est une des rares truc
voilà vous avez malgré les blessures et
le courant c'est bien de pouvoir
assister là dessus et donc soit il va
jouer une sorte de française 6 pouces e5
ce que je ferais côté blanche soit parce
que là si c'est pas un coup de génie
dans la vente d' avance de la française
après sa strate jouable permettre à des
plans que me fous des sept fous b5 ou
quoi mais bon
mais alors pourquoi il essaie de viser
ça parce qu'il pense que guy est pas
super dans la française où justin a pas
de répertoire très bien foncé sont pour
un faible il veut juste jouer une partie
joue un coup moi je pense que ça joue
découvre donc en cas rien qui met un
artemiev champions d'europe 2 800 en
2018 champion d'europe deux partis
classiques en 2019 il a gagné le très
fort tournoi de gibraltar seul qui a un
gros titres c'est un énorme joueur
artemiev qui n'a pas forcément eu la
chance d'avoir les bonnes invitation
dans les bons tourner au bon moment
voilà bon après les encore jeune mais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage pour lui
parce que j'aurais bien aimé tu vas le
voir au moins dans les grands prix fille
d'un truc comme ça lui donne une chance
de le candidat là sa seule chance était
digne du monde c'est évident c'était pas
facile et donc son point faible
peut-être les ouvertures ce qui est le
point fort de guiry mais en dehors de ça
à mon avis il joue à deux trois classes
au-dessus de l'autre ouais bah surtout
en rapide mais met clairement un gears
hyper bien préparés connais bien ces
trucs et donc artémias peut faire qu'il
trouve des petits systèmes des petits
trucs pour ne pas se faire planter de
l'ouverture il évite le point fort
adverse et après il peut se débrouiller
on dit qu'il ya artemiev a l'air fatigué
alors il faut savoir qu'il en sibérie je
pense qu'il ya quatre heures de décalage
avec nous
dès 22h je pense que les 22h ou 23h il
faut aussi savoir qu'en sibérie à cette
époque de l'année il fait nuit quasiment
tout le temps cette terrible il fait
tout le temps nuit il fait froid
votre ouais ouais non c'est moi j'ai
vécu ici assez longtemps pendant une
dizaine d'années déjà j'habitais à
moscou lit verte est pas toujours au
mieux à cette période de l'année parce
que quand tu voit plus du tout le soleil
et qui fait froid tout le temps matt
était plus fatigué que moi c'est normal
c'est c'est le corps humain qui est
comme ça mais alors en sibérie c'est
terrible c'est pire que tout
et pourquoi vivre en sibérie mais il est
né là-bas sibérien de gains et les
syriens sont généralement la réputation
des gens très gentils
ce qu'on disait il à l'argentine et
sibérien bailleur iakovenko qui est
sibérien un joueur de haut niveau
c'est un gars super sympa la réputation
d'être des gars saint-palais les
sibériens non même temps pas mauvais
choix
iakovenko est très bons joueurs aussi
mais ils ont un grand club et le club de
tomsk en sibérie
il ya une culture un peu il ya un peu
d'argent qui investit yahia crantée
mansiisk aussi la ville russe qui
organise beaucoup de tournois la sibérie
c'est une république d'une région de
russie qui est assez active niveau haut
niveau aux échecs avec notamment je
crois que c'est un député je sais pas
qui qu'investit qui s'appelait quatre
chefs
le hasard le bien nommé tout cas ça se
passe pas super bien c'est s'il y en a
six françaises qui rit bien là on nous
dit quand il et il est même y quelqu'un
qui m'aime 00h13 en ce moment en sibérie
s'est cassé quatre avec moscou alors tu
vois j'ai tellement vécu à moscou que
j'avais l'impression c4 mais c'est parce
qu'elles le font jouer à ce moment-là
équilibré bah du coup quand magnus je
t'annonce qu'il a aux sciences en eau
car en fait parce que quand tu vas jouer
de minuit à 4 heures du mat c'est
impossible 4 heures du matin tu tiens
pupin tu te laisses des pièces en un
tout été dépêchés tu peux parler surtout
à cette période de l'année mais je suis
en a pu jouer à 14 heures c'était
lang est restée 14 heures pour lui toi
bien et puis lui bah ça n'était que 20
heures à minuit c'était une âme ils
disent qu'ils à omsk il ya trois heures
de décalage horaire mais dans tous les
cas 23 heures 3 heures du mat pour un
match comme ça alors je pense que
conduire il est tellement plus fort qui
va qui va la gagner mais c'est
clairement handicap s'écarter bien fait
un des acteurs principaux de la série
walking dead c'est pas mal ça là oui bon
c'est pas s'est passé pas les choses
qu'on aime trop avec fab
on aime bien quand il ya un jour
d'équité qui est suivi on n'aime pas
trop ce truc lâm après c'est aussi et on
a sur internet
malheureusement il ya décalage horaire
mais même en plus artemiev c'est un gars
qu'on aime bien quoi c'est pour ça qu'on
est là mais en gros justement tu
pourrais peut-être trouver un
arrangement pour tout le monde dirige
pour jouer à 18 heures ou à 14 heures ça
peut aller changer grand chose
alors pour atténuer que ça change
beaucoup apprécié une journée double
match tu peux faire mal à retenir 14h et
faire un autre match dans la foulée à 18
heures voilà par exemple va veut dire si
tu peux vraiment faire d'arrangement
parce que c'est chiant pour tout le
monde qui avec 1 australien mais je sais
pas où bon c'est la vie qui fixe une
heure et puis c'est comme ça mais là bon
mais oui j'aime bien quand c'est faire
donc les échecs c'est censé justement un
train un jeu qui sait faire c'est à dire
je joue chacun ton tour tu as une
position symétrique au début et c'est
enfin un billet direct pour se
rééquilibrer
bon ben justement on va te dira non mais
toi tu ne dormira pas on voit ça change
un peu sur aix vieilli écrit glénat anam
c'est pas un sibérie à
oms qui ce que ce en sibérie ou pas mais
ça pas être loin de toute façon et puis
peut-être que ses parents sont sibérien
enfin en tout cas moi j'ai toujours
entendu en russie quand on parle d'art
tu es lièvre on dit le joueur sibérien
enfin c'est donc comme guy on dit le
batave effet qu'il prendrait 5 c'est un
peu le bordel dans cette partie design
serait en sibérie bailly coûte-t-il vila
do conde plus malheureusement elle est
très mal développés je pense que
j'arrive à prendre a trait à la dame au
milieu pas de faire comme tous les
quatre
après je vois pas de gain immédiat pour
les blancs juste salaire ça leur chante
quoi je vais créneau mais après si tu
survis alors on n'entendait plus à la
dame je sais pas où j'ai saint cloud
pour avoir mais bien qu'il a vu fou
prend ici et d'avoir joué un petit coup
un petit coup de de la fouille et 6e
chez phone web os x 10 6 pour west ham
en fêtes de peyrens je suis fou ces six
là il gagne un tempo sur la dame
bon il est pas très beau encore au mieux
je pense aux f6 maintenant on a je pense
c'est son idée sur foot pro à schwyz
vous prend à chaud je crois que le
cahier bézu se déroule à ressortir ouais
mais l'autre affaire fois m6 soit une
fille ce qui arrive six dames c3 l'un
étant pied dans le premier 6-2 1-6 et
tours j'ai vite un truc comme ça
j'ai peur d'un pro v6 phase d'un
processus oui ce qui est plus fort tout
à fait naturel c'est fini tout cas la
finale tu vas perdre à six est mort
aujourd'hui 6 et 5
vous allez voir des 5 tu perds tout moi
qui ai mes gars il peut rater ça je suis
très fier
c'était tellement facile tard francis
mais bon on guérit les positions g est
toujours bien mais ça donne du jeu enfin
c'est tout ce qu'il voulait juste pour
dire le point faible il n'y a pas de
kate en plus fait oui je sais ça gagner
juste les pions mais à mes fils pour
dire avec guiry normalement son point
faible c'est la transformation des
positions gagnantes
c'est pour ça qu'il faut s'accrocher bon
en fait il n'a pas de calage demande
d'amm prince et six mais là non plus
mais oui à encore tour c6 qui rentrent
il ya de tout bon à quelle heure tu es
de ma bonne structure car au moins bien
des détours pas connecté tu as beaucoup
de trucs chiants mais bon pourcentage en
moins mais il n'y a pas de gain évident
pour les blancs pour l'instant
d'ailleurs tu vois je me demande si
gehrig fait beaucoup de nuls c'est un si
bon défenseur je crois qu'il est très
fort pour obtenir un avantage dans
l'ouverture
il manque beaucoup de positions
avantageuses mais je sais pas s'il est
si bon que ça en défense en soi non pas
non pas tant que ça juste qu'ils voient
ça y est solide il est celui de bon quoi
mais il quand il est mal
non j'ai plafonds qui sont vraiment des
trucs miraculeux tu vas te crack il dit
mathieu mathieu cornette si le connais
un peu et qui veut laisser aucun contre
jeu car il a peur du coup ils gâchent
trop ouais mais c'est c'est dur d'avoir
peur mais seuls pas que ce bus c'est un
truc incontrôlable des fois tu le sais
tu dis ok job ça les fameuses attaques
de panique ça existe au delà des échecs
mais ça peut être facile à gagner
il est un pion de plus mais du coup le
tournoi consacriez je ne sais pas
conduire juger mais je pense que nul
c'est le moteur propre bar en plus ce
truc à elle c'est qu'il fait à quatre
qui ont passé tu vas prendre une tour en
b2b tendance plus nette avance
parrainant tu vas te faire bloquer tu
vas te faire prendre un sandwich leurs
ouailles à ranger set il a besoin
talât petit tour au tas situe à tour
bouge ça peut être un petit tour f5 pour
provoquer fkt bien bloqué le roi comme
il faut mais c'est pas juste en face il
y aura toujours bouger à tour f5 triste
ristournes jeu et on prend elle fait mal
ça là pour guy en réalité je trouve un
fab
ça peut être un sérieux qu'on va revoir
assez souvent
ouais si si elle ferme est ok
comment dire il nous joue ça et hier tu
es bien possible donc fait moins jouer
bien sûr que les autres sicilienne mais
pourquoi pas vous faut trois ans pour
joël d'amd 2 et pouvoir éventuellement
échanger les fous de gasoil donc comme
prévu artemiev qui évite fable et gros
débats théoriques et qui va et déjà
c'est logique de favori mais toute façon
il est juste tout le temps ça donc c'est
même pas un truc spécial est aujourd'hui
différent c'est étrange d'ailleurs à ce
niveau là de ne jamais avoir vraiment
réussi à construire un répertoire
d'ouvertures solide
est ce que c'est parce qu'il est mal
entouré ce que c'est il a une mauvaise
mémoire est ce que je sais pas
après disons soit perthois être très
bien jusqu'à un certain niveau a presque
le top mondial c'est carrément mis la
barre très très haute dire si je joue
contre moi il est très bien préparée il
n'y aura aucun problème
mais non c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
évident à régler comme problème et
artemiev a jamais réussi à le faire
cependant il se joue des petits plans et
guiry qui je suis étonné un geek joue
pas plus vite
je pense qu'au fur qui est des quatre
ici vient vont tomber pour copains qui
s'est fait croquer eu deux watch quatre
rouges points tout comme sa maison que
je pensais que j y arriverai bien
préparée contre les petits systèmes
partenaires parce qu'il veut toujours à
peu près la même chose
vraiment fait du coup les gars pages de
ce à quoi je m'attendais trois c4
il a joué une fois des cadres des quatre
et est là et la 6ème fermé j'ai pas trop
me souviens avoir joué
ce qui est intéressant c'est que tu
aurais peut-être cavaliers des uns ici
voilà ce qui est thématique pour forcer
3 c'est pas con d'avoir attendu que le
camion de deux parce que moi tu peux
échanger de repartir chez eux comme
twilight ce sas intérêt là qu'ailleurs
c'est hyper souvent joué là dessus
dès lors je défends b2 et en plus tu
peux faire c'est 3 mais tout ça
éventuellement des quatre ans le centre
à ses principes qui changent pas aux
échecs
qu'on soit débutant fabouly gaye ou top
mondial l'objectif c'est sur ces trois
des quatre de prendre le centre avant de
tenir
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il ya une sorte de
règles à connaître avec les noirs pour
soir quand tu le faire qu'il y ait des 4
ou pas c'est quand les blancs menace de
faire des quatre mêmes dates à pornic il
le fasse parce que tu rentres dans une
sorte sicilienne normale en termes de
structure et je pense que ça faiblit un
peu le pion des six des choses comme ça
pas menacer une ferme et les noirs sont
pas trop et laisser les blancs faire des
quatre facilement moi j'aime bien je
pense à bien aimer les blancs il va
échanger et il va avoir soif 4,5 et le
droit soit ces trois des quatre vingt il
a plein d'idées mais je pense que je
dois pas trop mal pour les noirs non
plus mais oui quelques 3000 logique
d'agir en partant dans un d'une
ouverture un peu insipide tu vois pas
très théorique entre guillemets un bien
sûr mais tu est réputé pas excellent je
trouve qu'il a une position était
content tu joues quoi ouais ouais mais
la seine fermés ce festival se livrant
une ouverture pour jouer en fait je
ferai pas de système bancaire qui
égalise complètement juste une partie
sauf à être et donc c'est pas mal et du
coup on nous demandait c'est la dernière
le dernier match des huitièmes de finale
à rouyn et il y aura des belles affiches
en quarts puisque y aura un maxime
vachier lagrave numéro quatre mondial
numéro un français contre les bonnes
aronian qu'israël est remonté numéro 9
mondial ce sera un beau duel en car il y
aura icare onac
murat contre donc murat mondiale en
blitz contre fedoseyev qui a surpris
mais on va voir ce qui donne qui peut
même pas sûr qu il est bon il y aura wes
les sauts qui a été double finaliste des
speechs s dans les deux années
précédentes et qui jouera en quart
contre duda qu'on a vu hier dangereux et
donc là il y aura magnus carlsen le
champion du monde on ne le vainqueur de
ce match donc on va dire sûrement mais
bon on verra mais donc 40 scènes qui
pourraient avoir un quart de finale
forcément favori de façon vous pourrez
le voir jouer à son meilleur niveau quoi
qui pourrait l'obliger droite pourrait
l'obliger à jouer à son meilleur niveau
oui carbeo la partie des quarts de
finale il ya plus de il ya plus de semis
affiche pas tout est très intéressant
ouais donc bien faire f5 wave ont
souvent les verts font ça pour un peu
stoppé justement l'avancé blanche de ce
côté après ce qu'ont fait ces trois des
quatre matchs a toujours tenté par ces
trois mais bon en fait on fait ces trois
des quatre et ils en prennent quatre
je suis parce qu'on accomplit énorme
mais bon c'est trois fois sur un coup
bon allez il ramène ce qu'est ce centre
pourquoi pas il se prépare l'ouverture
de la position tu as peut-être des g4
peuvent partir aussi un jour j'ai quatre
ça peut être sympa
il prend un ipad jouer la colonne ouais
en fait tu peux acquéreurs souvient de
prendre à l'opposé et que j'ai mais pour
le secteur réussi ça peut faire
peut-être et a pris comme ça quel fou
prend beissat d'alger deux autres comme
ça forge la casse des 5
ouais et sur des cinq peut-être qu'ils
essaient quatre étudiants de singles
c'est bien juste la dame g2 l'idée c'est
lui qui a aidé 5 s'installer sur des
cinq pour empêcher qui c'est quatre puis
on prend on ferait dans le premier set
et on gagnerait la case de 5
c'est un petit avantage ce petit truc la
preuve on s'est peut-être vu à trouver
que ça pour ça ces juges a fait cavalier
c4 aidé à me prendre moi et ça revient à
porte même un nom mais va les soumettre
cinq juges nommés à vie
yasar bas il a raté je pense donc ça
c'est c'est un sacrifice de déviation a
été qu'elle prend à ses 1 comprend un
pion on se dit ah oui mais il a seul à
pied c'est complètement débile mais en
fait il a dévié la dame et prend sur
échec en plus donc ça sera encore le
trait au prochain donc guiry qui fait
cette faute tactique qui a raté qui
avait prend 1,5 et sa fab à ce niveau là
c'est une donnée un pion en un coup
comme ça c'est une énorme erreur oui
grosse faute ça c'est une erreur que
même déjà à nos niveaux avec fab donc
encore plus à celui de femme combien
mais on peut déjà plus se permettre ce
genre d'erreur normalement tu fais été
dégoûté c'est dramatique quoi ça tu
avais une balle tranquille mi-court
couloir quoi n'importe quoi sans
chercher à faire un coup gagnant pour
autant résultats vais jouer jouer non
plus qui a et b 3 ea ayant plus à la
tour qui arrive en cinq ans au 1 et a
faim il ya tout qui rentre la fab en
fait il a le même avantage positionnelle
de base pour tous permet avec les cases
centrale un peu une équipe où ruffier
notamment le cinq donc et avec un pion
bonus gagner dans l'escarcelle donc donc
c'est plutôt cool et la d4 j'adore parce
que s'il prend alors contact le cavaly
menacera damien aussi sphère des
fourchettes live à néant ses 5es à bail
est super bien que non il le domine à sa
main quand même bien donc il force pas
avec les blancs et jacques blanc
artemiev ne force pas tout court voilà
et euh non mais c'est ce qu'on aime
c'est ce qu'ont pour ça qu'on aime ce
jour artemiev c'est qu'il a un style de
jeu vraiment a l'impression que les
parties elles coulent quoi c'est un
filet de soi ouais c'est un filet de
soirée c'est un pilier de soi mais
vraiment je guéris a regagné son pion
mais le problème c'est qu'il est
complètement ligoté dans une pression
donc c'est pas comment les blancs il va
passer maintenant mais il ya une liberté
de manoeuvre que les normands pas vous
trouver généralement quand tu sais pas
ça hk page 5 1 c'est très bien jusqu'à
3,5
trois peut-être g4 qui à partir surtout
kf4 ça pas vraiment à l'heure parce que
toujours l'histoire fourchette donc je
pense qu'il pouvait dire cavaliers ccim
quoi poursuit clarisse et signe qu ici
paca et c5 important mais c'est tres non
oued avait fait 13 mois et tu parle
espagnol à fond là quand tu es bien
comme ça il n'y a plus un mot français
et la pioche et quattro tu vois c'est ça
cool quoi plus un coup franc des tours
troyes il vat encaissé le but et le
petit ses tresses c'est parti horrible
t'as pas un bon coup en fait tu fais
juste des coups pour essayer de pas
perdre direct non juste le scénario de
la partie fait mal parce que l'autre en
fait ils te donnent une leçon
enfin il te dis oui enfin pourquoi tu
joues mais stade pour dire mais non mais
il fait des mauvaises parties pour
l'instant la première vous parlez un peu
j'ai pas tout suivi mais juste peur
d'une action directe et voilà la seconde
les hyper bien et il rend l'avantagent
sans trop s'en servir et là celle-là un
massacre selon qui est la prochaine doit
être dire bon après ok il ya en a vu
caruana qui menait 3 0 qui essaie de
faire tourner mais c'était différent
c'était pas le même importe de faire
sans on savait qu'il y avait un gros
avantage en bullet pour un des deux
joueurs là là je crois que les avantages
en plus facile pour artemiev en plus
3240 contre 3062 oui en fait en bullet
mais je suis sûr j'ai déjà vu à retenir
joue en bullet des potes alors j'adore
ce joueur après moi je suis un peu fade
et oui face et c'est pas la même classe
1 c'était beau et chaque petit tour au 6
août je peux tout réussit
or quelques fois huit c'est beau quand
tu arrives était fatigué défoncé tu as
juste mettre une mine quoi
je pense si tu doubles sur la huitième
tu l'humilie un peu dans the rage comme
qui j'ai cru que guy est plus fort règne
encore tout perdu ça démarre mal on va
dire pour lui mais il n'a pas encore
perdu ça alors par contre il ya il
défend il défend pas mal un peu dans la
merde donc ça touche plus grosse faute
de 6 à ces 2 et 10 et contre attaquer un
terrible artemide tu veux la laisser sur
la huitième pour défendre ton cheval
comment le procès de et tour à un matin
baden prend deux échanges et je prends
ici ont la poisse et de ouf quoi
[Rires]
complètement gagnant voilà ce qu il est
déjà tard chez lui ah non mais ça c'est
sûr que aussi tard thüga fin ça c'est
bien
on est un peu dégoûté là non bon ben
c'est la crème dire il va pas le rater
c'est très bien payé pour guy ci annule
après trois parties le physionomie des
partis il ya pas un genre de pâte qui
peut se préparer ça serait bien mais le
gastronome en culottes courtes la taille
peut prendre l'aventage parce que
certaines se refait une ouverture à lui
qu'il arrive c'était quoi devant des
goûters là ça s'en va
bakou c'est pas très grave mais oui ils
devaient gagner cette partie n'a jamais
été tellement bien c'est parce qu'il a
foutu hamster foutu parce que justement
plus les tours qui rentrait 8e tour et
puis tout d'un coup
tout d'un coup il a oublié ses deux quoi
je pense en fait ouais je sais pas ce
qu'il a fait c'était arrive le chat qui
part en gie rira bien qui rira le
dernier
il a bien il agit rigolez pas c'est
terrible g45 jazz mettant des pages et
4ème ça a l'air fort c'est intéressant
tout au moins en fait on a bien sûr
l'habitude de voir les blanches comme ça
avec l'occurrence et 2 mai mais la
salade aux noix roxy mais en fait ma foi
pourquoi pas puisque le roi en bas pour
le sacre à rien tu te garde grande
possible ou juste faire rock your wife 2
ce que tu veux donc intéressant
intéressant mais nord voir qu'ils
arrivent à percer quelques barres de fer
des cinq dans jal c'est le coup mais bon
pour l'instant tu as du mal à envisager
qu'on c'est possible ou pas en simple
comme b5 à un manque sacrifions pour
ensuite faire des cinq pales pas un
grésillement fab
non c'est bon c'est parti c'est parti le
téléphone qu'ils un truc
ouais je sais pas du tout mon téléphone
était proche de du micro donc qu'on sait
jamais si je reçois des trucs je me
demandais si ça venait pas de mes
écouteurs mais c'est confirmé par le
chat c'était bien ça faisait bien du
micro personne ne l'entend sauf moi mais
c'était probablement le téléphone elle
téléphone à rénover en fait tu as tu
peux plus parler espagnol coté vladislav
artémias vois tu dis est vieille dame
des vies j'ai six cavaliers c5
il n'y a pas trop d'espacé c'est vrai
mais bon
solide un bon moi j'aime pas trop la
pression ne durerait
et
juste avait dit le joueur qui aime bien
sûr position en fait à ressorts août a
pas d'espacé justement trois adversaires
il prend ses aises il avancé d'avant ça
montre que contrer parce que il s'est
offert extrême des combinaisons anglais
sont logés dimas 3 avancé et il va
tenter à un moment un dessin 15,5 un
truc comme ça pourra faire ça un jour en
fait faut juste bien de taille mais mes
poissons c'est notre agréable je l'écris
blanc parce que tu te fais bien défoncé
et crina je vois pas le contrôle
j'arrivais à me 17 sur m6 il veut 5 ha
et kf5 encore on sait du rhin je pensais
6e 5e et ça marche paraît non là il est
il est dans le dur
j'ai vu sauter les yeux plusieurs fois
voilà un café faut prendre un truc un
red bull voir red bull oui ce que tu
veux mais il faut prendre quelque chose
là bas il est il est très très mal les
lattes on rentre pas en jeu le roi au
centre
t'as pas de plan en fait c'est tout bref
deux tours achat prises puis semble
enfin tu as deux dois te prendre b4
sookie c5 a pas de case bon il à la casa
4 mais bon c'est tout un tas de toile
verte jarret ce serait malheureux pour
de bon mazeau il sera à deux doigts de
gagner la can en bas il à deux doigts de
faire des cinq dames j'ai trois trucs et
ouais mais cahier dé 3,4 à deux doigts
de gagner si vous le dis maso il serait
content à yves ballot il serait très
heureux je vous contre un fish les amis
qu'ils feront toutes les cases de
l'échiquier qui a aidé cette il va
revenir en 5 mais on va dire et écrire
enfin c'est déprimant cause de je sais
qu'elle est c'est terrible
télécom g6 qui peut partir parce que je
prends pas possible elle prend tu perd
2,6 sinon juste à mach 2 peut être un ou
roi je sais pas quoi et tourache un
câble et où enfin t'as plein de trucs
appétissant probable d'un match de
paraître le move for parce que tu as ta
cage s'est tu te replaces sur cette
diagonale une faute à prix 1,7 après tu
feras un petit g6 au bon moment avec a
appris à gstaad à mon avis et c'est la
mort on va voir comment on thiery innu
gers à une voiture on va prendre de
risque donc de faire un truc le safe
d'après les infos de mathieu sur son
style mais damage de sa part he said we
made you fait savoir être le coup
parfait s'est attaqué tut tut tut tut
laisse rien de rien ouais enfin ce qui
va tenter un quart à lieusaint qui va
laisser prendre à ce jeu ça estimé ces
deux c'est pareil que le roi peut-être
ai-je voulez quoi
mais là pour le coup rtbf ou comme qui
trouve trouve quoi jouer sur quatre
parce que ça fait deux parties ou autant
avec les blancs avril à dominer 2 la
partie d'avant il doit la gagner
donc ça c'est pas le problème mais par
contre côté noir ça se passe pas bien
premier se passe très mal
alors on va avoir un mic les noirs il a
des vrais problèmes
après je crois que son nouveau toit
principal 107 lacarrau cannes mais s'est
pris quelques quelques pistaches dessus
bon après c'est solide
carita vallier eux deux n'écoutez pas ce
qu'il veut probablement d'aller d'autres
vérifient katusha m 5 quand même et
peut-être qu'il ya eu 5 3 17 tu vois je
sais pas je me livre à 17 ce peut être
un terrain je le dis ce plan là peut
être intéressant je pas si j'ai raison
aussi j'ai tard pourquoi parfaite j'ai
vachement de mal à dire ce que je
pourrais jouer avec les noirs c'est un
peu déprimant la position mais en gros
quand c'est comme ça faut pas faire
d'erreur en 1 pas perdre direct met en
place qui était mon entraîneur m'a
toujours appris décès jouer un coup de
plus tout le temps sans rien donner
et peut-être un jour ça sourit quoi
enfin attendre en fait c'est ça ouais
c'est pas ce qu'il ya de plus marrant à
faire mais bon est-ce qu'on est toujours
sur un match sans suspense par mois ça
que j'avais pas pris en compte le fait
que artemiev joue en pleine nuit en fait
je n'avais pas anticipé le fait qu'ils
jouent à 23h30 près lui et qui risque de
finir le match à 3 heures du mat
donc le fait qu artemiev je vous en
manque de sommeil pour moi équilibre
complètement les débats quoi bah disons
la partie devant des cadeaux mais ça
ressemble vraiment à des cadeaux de
fatigue un parti n'avance donc il me
semble que ouais que le fuseau horaire
très désavantageux pour artemiev à
équilibre complètement le match mais à
d'autres à partir un rodez vite jusqu'à
huit excès dans les soutes cases noires
partie avec tour ses lutins jours c'est
très loin ce que je raconte j'ai pas si
tu peux y avait complètement à part ça
autres sont peut faire je vous rajoute
pas d'autre plan en fait presque même
pas n'importe qui qui rit ah oui dont
bien sûr ce portier mais en fait en gros
il est juste moins fort que son
adversaire qui lui aussi n'est pas
n'importe qui donc il fait 4 ans avait
quatre c'est pas parce que du coup en
fait même si perrache ça tu pourras à se
dire je suis à 3 v iii allait le roi et
le invs et de l'autre côté il ay léo il
est ok pour moi quoi
while à la nasa il est il est marié et
d'un gamin en bas âge aussi artemiev
jamais donc j'ai pas et tu joues en
pleine nuit
tu as enfin en fait le nombre de
problèmes qu'il a pour ce match assez
impressionnant un beauf qui tombe à
l'eau ces huîtres ou déjà cette fois ci
ce qu'il veut partir mais sur l'un des
cinq échecs tu vois je voudrais aider
cette superbe et 4 le ton puis de fait
des 5 ce qui va faire d'ailleurs tu as
même sur kelly s'est peut-être cinq
aussi j'aime pas fait gaffe était donc
tu multiplies les petites tentatives
c'est toujours pas une belle position
mais 300 guy a toujours pas gagné cette
il n'y a pas de menace directe bon kid
et ça je crois pour le faire et
maintenant et maintenant elle sur dmb
kata peut-être 5 août et 5 l'un ou
l'autre ou les deux à la fois ci cela
qui menace a aussi oublié
en fait il fait juste carrément dans la
merde qui rit ce que tu as deux vraies
menaces en vrai ils ont dit prends aussi
sur x 6,5 et 6,7 km h est aussi dans les
idées ok fois ci ce qui est triste
d'apprendre à me prend 1,6 attention
vous bien de faire dans ce sens ainsi
fait dame principe d'un point gagné
chaque ouais ok c'est ça donne prendre
en bref c'est peut-être donc là il
arrive cette fois je suis teint comme
menaçante en parlait à l'instant mon fab
web bref ça serait cool je jouerai un
tué roi bloqueurs et tu tiens les cases
blanches sur la diagonale qui joue plus
vite un et bloque aussi et peut-être
prise prise 2 600 euros 18 la vie côté
mais bon ça doit te des dames sierra il
ya des échecs en bas il est mal autant
il ya cinq secondes mais bondir il a que
30 un autre côté si je reviens vite
puis surtout que des prendre 5 tu prêt
move va relater en prix chocs
donc ça va et si tu le fais pas tu vas
vite je pense que tu vas jouer mais tu
vas jouer un coup quoi donc prise aie
aie fait dames c'est un avant ok
peut-être un peu pourquoi pourquoi ce
que j'aime pas trop section dame
adacore bien joué il veut dame c5 et
prendre le sac de la dame
des traces de conneries du ou alors
peut-être allons jamais roi des dossiers
d'amm prend juste 5mb fichier 3 un peu
de sérieux
bref cette je sais pas quel chirurgie
comme andré larente zite note
honnêtement on va peut-être vont faire
état des dessins qui vont partir ses 5e
jeux même si la dame des sept échecs de
l'autre côté ça tape à l'oeil nu look et
m'écoutent le ce match 300 c'est le bal
des occasions manquées gens m'aiment
bien eux s'ils rentrent dans le tchat
sur les cernes d'arreter njawe qui font
peur ça c'est vrai qu'il fait un peu
peur quoi ça vole des kits pour le joker
qua non est le prochain jeu car je vais
faire c'est le joker méchant avec les
cernes noires et a en fait il n'ya même
pas besoin de mettre le maquillage quoi
il les ados fils et naturellement en
joker parce qu'il aura un futur joker
alors je pense que je referai un joker
oui c'est pas tu peux tous le faire tu
gères double face
non mais si on joue contre hikaru vu
qu'on a battu gotham la dernière fois
j'aimerais bien avoir un match contre
hikaru quand même on a le droit voire se
frottent léger avec du charbon terrible
terrible coup j'ai devancé la petite
nimzat ouais alors c'est peut-être
daghfous des deux qui s'est
malheureusement moderne de jeu toi je
suis pas un expert du truc c'est un coup
au japon que j'avais quasiment jamais vu
de ma vie encore quelques aides qui
pourtant son principal et radio mais
nantes où claude tchou b4 que des
couleurs chaudes et deux naïdes mons
peyo ouais donc à aider cet art
maintenant est ce que tu peux essayer de
jouer la colonne des voix en disant que
tu as que vouloir gagner un tempo quoi
pour pour tripler éventuellement ouais
je trouve que ce soit pour les noirs
quoi depuis qu' on va peut-être une
blague énorme fan je te coupe mais j'ai
quand même du mal à cerner l'humour du
chat bien pressé désolé ça tu as coupé
mais la blague la blague méritait d'être
lu bondam cette envie qui rit un petit
loupé d'étudiants en lettres en 5ème
arrondissement à paris
c'est pas fou c'est désolant c'est le
style moi c'est normal tu as le pion des
six qui va être sous pression tu triple
vite quand même ouais voilà bon les
noirs ils vont prenant soin le défendre
soi faire contre lui sur ses mais bon
tout catane petites cibles ne me prend
leur destin pour dames et où je peux
jurer prix d'album 103 fichier mais
s'attache 3 mais bon ça mène à rien et
tous ses tours ses huit obligé
d'attaquer mais bon bien sûr tour sens
où tu prends des six si tu fais tour 17
au moins tu peux dire j'ai envoyé la
sauce ian marchant sur tours d ici si on
veut faire un dame b cet intermédiaire
puis prendre ces quatre pour se parer
quoi enfin j'imagine que c'est son idée
d'un f4 écoute bonne défense et 4éme
nasa prises des 6 avec l'idée de mettre
la tour en d1
je pense qu'il peut avoir une vente
juste marrante bon il ça va se passer
mais à passe-passe et n'inquiète pas bon
ya pas match malheureusement mais je
vais montrer ce genre d'idée on peut
emporter reda mais fuite mais ça peut
être le genre d'idées qui fait que quand
tu prends des cistes et devant quoi
à coup de pression technique je pense
qu'ils pourraient se font bien artemiev
veut dire qu elle a gagné mais n'a pas
besoin de calculer je tape bien placé
les pièces et sait faire
karting est fan du look de l'étudiant en
sciences du 5e arrondissement
c'est vrai qui dort pas la nuit parce
qu'il a trop de trop d'études peuvent
apprendre de l'ada monde assez sympa
pour prendre un grand pas facile
français 4e tour du tour 17
tu bouffes un pur ou calcul quoi bon
tampon décidemment way quatre tours d
autour de 7
mais bien sûr tu gagnes option est vrai
et bon c'est déjà ça c'est quoi leur
rang mondial alors dire il est plein la
trémie afida reculer moi je peux je peux
mais on va dire qu'ils sont moins bien
classé que leur niveau en six ans ils
sont loin de leur de leur top quoi avons
grillé ou ce 11e mondiale est à retenir
il a bien reculé les 33 ouais mais alors
quand blitz moi je mettrais top 20 mais
alors sans réfléchir et peut être même
top-15 quoi on glisse jean
en plus il est l'heure des filets 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 mondial on s'est demandé d'en
but c'est sûr que c'est un gros blitzer
donc dans la cadence artemiev c'est
clairement un top 10 mondial en
puissance un laguérie qui sue à la
caméra il se rend compte qu'il a perdu
un pion mais c'est bizarre 20 meilleurs
tu es maintenant que je vais faire à
quelques sites pour battre aussi de la
fidh
tu peux trouver dessus tout donc la fidh
fédération internationale des échecs et
l'a jeté à les voir sur 2700 live qui
est un site qui suit en direct et
l'évolution des classements quoi qui est
bien petit martin roy faisant il est pas
très beau side est moche complètement
mai
les impôts sont bonnes et il est mis à
jour en temps réel donc c'est tout ce
que je demande
mathieu qui proposait à 5
bonjour appuyons prend puis on les anges
et sur 3 et 3,7 pour f3 peut être oui ça
ce que c'est ce que je calcule aimé la
torah 4 était très bien placé mais
j'aurais fait comme dirait ou en fait et
c'est à dire dès l'es4 et le roi et je
vois un conte 0 de l'autre côté ce qu'on
va y arriver
du coup ça c'est quoi je pense
objectivement ça être gagnée en ans pour
les blancs sur jeu parfait puisqu'il ya
quatre contre quatre c'est pas 3.23
d'avoir assez de pions de l'autre côté
pour la gagne et non
voilà je fais déjà 4 etc les blancs
moment h4 g14 là bas tu évites tacle
énorme mettre leur tête g4 des quais ou
trois c'est pas mal sur un bouquet pour
leur ôter son moi tu as de la chance de
gagner surtout que c'est le pion b
lectorat sera pas le pion à ça augmente
les chances de gain c'est le meilleur
non je crois le pion b de tous entre abc
des noms je sais pas je sais pas quel
est le meilleur mais est déjà baissé
mieux que ça et après par rapport à ces
je suis pas trop ces faux demande à vlad
il avait j'ai tout étudié j'ai tout fait
j'ai toujours su qu'il fallait garder
changer donc l'idée pourquoi on parle de
ab tout ça c'est qu'en fait à un moment
on imagine que artemiev qui va faire
tout bessette où tour à six il va
prendre ses pions les normands se ranger
sur l'a4 donc normal qu'ils ont passée
on va avancer les normes et à tour
derrière on aura besoin du roi pour le
soutenir pour aller à dame
donc le roi blanc va courir à l'el dames
on va perdre du temps pour ça et noël
aussi de faire du contrôle de l'autre
côté avancé leurs pions monter leurs
droits et à un moment mais les blancs
seront quasiment en train de faire le
pion b cette nouvelle embellie de faire
une promotion donc valoir sakhri latour
dessus et le roi va reprendre il sera la
bande des huit mais en fait des huit
c'est une colonne du prêche plus proche
que les huit fois par la loi et donc on
revient plus vite
donc ça peut être le temps qu'il fera la
différence à la toute fin
et là il échange ils donnent ni les gens
lèvent de compte j'ai quatre hockey
non non c'est pas là je ne sais pas
pourquoi pas il a enlevé le pion avancé
de l'adversaire après sa structure elle
un peu moche enfin je pense qu'il ya
toujours des bonnes chances pour gears
est de tenir c'est enfin j'étais plus
confiant il ya une dizaine de coups pour
hogan blanc après c'est jamais facile
hein non j'avais très souvent nul ce
truc en fait mais mais c'est assez
intéressant
il se passe plein de trucs c'est assez
compliqué et plein de subtilité et ses
jobs se maîtriser carrément cessé jamais
simple ça c'est toujours des parties à
des parties complexes qui peuvent qui
peuvent partir d'un côté ou de l'autre
côté à l'autre en nul ou en victoire
blanche quoi mais c'est jamais s'est
jamais fait ce truc là mais pour
l'instant il attend à pouvoir prendre
des décisions je pense avant tout à soi
et reprendre dès 6 ans il n'a pas pris
pour l'instant mais très attendu pourra
toujours revenir et le prendre ensuite
mais donc prendre b6 juste à kuta 4
c'est pour ça qu'il a peur sont appelés
tout de suite est ce que tu peux essayer
de partir et que tu auras donc et cebeci
avec deux nouveaux sites web et te dire
que l'autre va tankessé les pions mecque
du coup ses deux pions passé lié ce
n'est pas jean collin il s'obtient ils
seront ici cf 5 contre et du coup tu
seras plus près pas d'être heureuse soit
des saints row 2 3 f 5 il a fait rien on
l'a fait roi des trois-rois gk3 ces
trois dates en europe soit qu'on se
retrouve cet échec
ouais mon 3g 5 peu importe mais ça que
j'aurais bien fait aussi pour pas le
perdre en route
bon maintenant je redirai le roi le truc
c'est quand tu fais roi ses trois tours
ici un truc chiant c'est que si tu auras
b3 à tour aux trois échecs pour un
système pourra gk3 ces 3 tab est de 6
ouais tout reprend on prend et on
reprend ici ça c'est pas mal mais si j'y
suis sur le 6 car j'ai trois mais du
coup tu as prévu dans la salle on a du
bon c'est bon tu dois tout
c'est nickel elle défend de trois ans la
case des quatre en plus était content
c'est facile c'est 3b 6-1 6-3 6-3 au
vote même réussi mais en réalité plus
j'y pense je lui dis que messi c'est pas
qu'on prenne les deux marchent bien et
je sais pas ou guéris a merdé du coup
mais joli a reconnu mais ça c'est la
technique rue st c'est vraiment bien
français ce qui ce qu'il a fait problème
donc trouver 4 ce contrat pour deux ans
de mayroy c3 serait dégagé la tour
auquel pourra à la fois en cure à de
monter leur cycle en train de faire est
à la fois défendre l'option on pourra
venir soutenir son pion là-bas et le
problème des north qui n'ont pas gagné
de pion à lèvres ya toujours un à quatre
nous n'avons pas craypion passer lance
pour lui va avoir ses systèmes bonjour à
tous leroy b 8e tour ces trois mages en
effet comme ça aussi
hé bé sept des huit tours à troyes et
tours c'est un gros v8 3 à 7
on a trop de shediac et que toi qui fais
bouclier géométrie parfaite
tchao pantin belle et jolie cette finale
d'artemis entretien très très bien bah
écoute arthur qui changeront rien mais
pas sur la petrov
ok tu solide on a vu hier alors je mets
une cuisse et 3 voilà c'est le second
qui rentrent pas dans les recomposer il
va faire un truc solide avec petit rock
et soit il fera des cinq soit ces cinq
soit b6 je sais pas quel set up et
d'options qui voit assez bien
normalement mais bon le truc c'est que
il paris par de lointains peu un petit
retard de développement avec les noirs
on voit la différence 1 le pion au t4
qui a permis de prendre de l'espace et
mettre le fond en d3 et dual pions 10,6
et le fonds us est donc mais bon c'est
que c'est pas si grave ça c'est
symétrique
moi je pense un bon choix c'est beaucoup
mieux que le rendrait sicilienne où ces
faits dénoncés avant d'apprendre ça
donne ce qu'il trouve s'est fait
défoncer et qu'elle fait deux nuls quoi
donc là dessin qui va le carré en 17
voilà je me dis ça
c'est toujours ses six qui se regarde
j'aurais pas trop faible qui ça mais qui
est 17 ça me semble plus logique près
des 5 c'est pas mal la partie d'hier il
prend moins l'espace sont qui peut le
prendre
ouais bon à voir
mais deux options sont en effet ces 6 du
coup le pion des six peut être faible en
faveur puisque je veux pas tu sens que
tu as même chose de raté un truc un à la
fouine dame prend des huit étapes à roye
g2 et bien voilà ok il a vu vite un
rayon sur la la caméra et qui rit claude
leicher mais il a pris trop vite guéri
enfin il a dû croire que le gars fait la
question j'ai dit bon il est pas si qu
il ya deux ans un truc bon si vraiment
tu vois rien tu dis bon bah non il rend
jusqu'en mai sauf que l'on soit bon et
puis la baignade mais compte-tours
cavaliers pions donc c'est pas si nette
non c'est mal et il est plus il est plus
mieux et probablement même avec moins
bien habillée moins bien leurs missions
mais pas beaucoup non plus un mais cinq
ans plus de plonger casta fait bien peu
le roi donc la guérilla il appelle mu
n'a pas dé 6 tu vois quelqu'un il a même
de la chance en soi d'avoir d'impro cinq
missions normales artémias fille se
frotte les yeux mais d'une force assez
impressionnant quoi c'est pas si tu te
dire si je te bats même dans cet état là
quoi qu'est ce qu'on vient de la doua
remis à dormir oui pour être à ton
niveau
c'est terrible
mais c'est fou de passer rend la peine
pour lui je te jure que c'est non mais
en fait ouais là ce qui est terrible
c'est de le faire ça juste en revanche
ça je comprends pas très bien
oui c'est lui qui a accepté de jouer
aussi mais si t'as pas le choix tu as
pas le choix tu dis bon tant pis je joue
je joue mais en vente 10 web pour être
non ça fait franchement ça va être quand
tu le vois ce grâce se frotter les yeux
comme ça de fatigue ça fait un peu mal
au coeur
howe est un truc compliqué si je
voudrais américain de los angeles
on les a tellement décalage horaire que
forcément mettra des deux dans la merde
mais la lie et les moyen de s'arranger
un peu mieux par contre je t'annonce que
si c'est le même horaire pour le quart
contre carl scène c'est même pas la
peine de jouer
non mais on peut ne pas faire le match
sera aussi bien en fait mieux serait
mieux rien serait mieux on me rien
serait mieux mn mais en fait tu vas voir
juste artemiev qui d'habitude joue pas
mal qui va se faire planter tout le
temps toutes les parties et c'est peut
être votre à 25,02 ouais ça peut être un
gros score juste parce que le défend
enfin un contre un mais contre karzaï ne
peux pas te permettre de le rater trop
de tactique en 1 mais même ça te coûte
trois parties sur sur 20 c'est déjà trop
a eu déjà que après magnus plutôt fair
play a priori non oui oui non mais je
prends mes juges je pense qu'ils veulent
faire l'horaire 18h tout le temps et que
de mal heureusement
ce sera alors imposé que et que ce sera
18 heures mais neuf comme ça c'est pas
le point de bonus c'est pas du tout que
faire un caprice est à dire je veux
absolument que mozart n'ai pas dormi
mais enfin c'est pas énorme à 21h
d'ailleurs mais après même décalé son
sommeil être en forme pour une partie à
minuit je pensais pas évident tu as même
si toi ou moi demain on prenait la
décision
info si m je sais pas si tu peux
vraiment quel est ton rythme sur un
horaire aussi
aussi tardif je sais pas trop bas tu vas
tu vas pouvoir mais bon c'est assez
contraignant fait surtout c'est une vie
de famille à voir des choses comme ça tu
totaux jet lag
je sais pas en combien de temps tu
change en or l'âge biologique tu sais
pas si tu peux faire ça en une semaine
honnêtement bas il paraît tu vois quand
tu rentre de voyage
le jet lag c'est une heure par jour pour
recaler ton corps donc on donne tu dois
pouvoir modifier de sept heures après ça
c'est des petits trucs plus ou moins
vrai mais en groupe same thing c'est pas
bon pour la santé non plus de faire ça
rsa ça je veux bien croire que c'est pas
très bon pour la sabam c'est sûr ça peut
te bats en gros je pense c'est bien tu
le retour du soleil mais en fait tu te
lèves quand il fait jour touchant
différents voilà un cyber il ya quatre
heures de soleil par jour orange est à
dire bon battu dans tout le temps très
bon trio spéciaux il a du mal à faire
des progrès mais en fait ça va pour
gagner
là il a vraiment énormément de chance
guerrila de tomber là dedans terrible
j'ai même passé un bac plus facile à
jouer pour les blancs ici ça fait mal un
tutorat moquait aussi c'est être ok pas
de ça tu sais ça mais je pense que tu es
déjà dans la merde avec les noirs en
fait tu ailles le parquet hcca alliaura
roi g8
ouais mais tour vite vous vous flautre
qu'ayant g5y et une sonate attend
cavaliers h c'est non mais quoi
maintenant on réussit la passe et il l'a
évité ah oui oui je finirai this way
fait gens racistes qui abritera cette
oasis et les tours vitrées des 5 1 les
votes de madame mais bon voilà mes fils
en fait c'est le coup logique quoi qu'il
en soit ouais c'est pour éviter le tu
dégages lecavalier tu donnes de la place
pour le roi exactement les petits ports
la mena sans plus mais en gros je me
demande si qui a aidé et si c'était ça
faisait pas juste très mal en fait c'est
quelque chose qui est pas c'est ça ouais
[Musique]
avant tout reprend est jamais revenu
s'attend en plus touchante en baisse est
là c'est le festival à huy à fourche à
tomber ça devrait donc du coup c'est à
total qui s'est finie en fait sa grille
lamarti c'est une grosse erreur de rater
car il y ait des systèmes
oui mais ça s'est vite face et ses
trouvailles ça c'est clair que cette
preuve c'est pas un coup célia par un
énorme les vols de jeu quand même
aujourd'hui fab
non ça joue pas trop mal mais ouais ça
rappe dépression gagnante savate des
trucs par ci par là
il a raté le kava lieux saints clairac
le cas et des 6 en un an fins et je veux
bien que ce soit difficile mais c'est
des joueurs du top mondial
ouais non c'est pas si difficile la
carélie des six était vraiment pas dur
peut-être sur dame français de temps un
problème c'est qu'il ya des quatre parce
que surtout reprend tata encore un mat
avec 3,8 de fouine matt de marloux drive
hier c'était un peu en haut deux en
dessous niveau de jeu ouais bah en fait
le truc c'est que j'ai l'impression que
sow hikaru et carole scène ils sont
vraiment au-dessus du pont de façon
c'est eux qui sont tout le temps final
de tout et on a eu un super match firoud
déjà fait des cff et de ca falloir tu as
très chaud aussi n'arrête à ces quatre
joueurs qui s'attend à trois qui semble
être au dessus il ya eu un super match
mais dès que tu sors de ça en fait c'est
tu sens la différence de niveau tout de
suite c'est moins fort mais tu me diras
c'est comme au tennis à tu sors des cinq
premiers mondiaux tu vois tout de suite
la différence
oui mais des fois tu as quand même des
super matches genre questionner qui
était cool en fait s'ils comptent sur le
doigt du daim d'ardoisé sur les doigts
d'un pied quoi basse et comme là il ya
eu firoud déjà fait d'aussi fou tu t'y
attends pas que son insu permet à chaque
fois qu'il ya un match de wawrinka chez
pac en reprise et si bien que ça le
match mais je vis est pourquoi je vais
continuer en fait un bond bizarre une
caste pas n'importe qui
il n'a pas une wawrinka contre gaston
mais chez vaste espace show mais
peut-être force one team peut-être mais
bon le lancement de steam tu tapes quand
même dans le top mondial terre battue je
tape mon avis ils sont les deux top 4
instituts dit nadal djoko tim shearman
tu as les quatre meilleurs joueurs de
terre battue du monde donc oui on t'a
bien là-dedans tape dans le top 4
mondial aussi encore une fois mais mais
oui oui tout ça pour dire que là c'est
un peu la même chose et que dès que tu
sors du gotha c'est un peu moins fort
bon mais au moins pour l'instant ça
reste relativement serré même si on sent
que retenir au dessus franchement à part
ça c'est ce qu'on aurait plus de base
mais ça fait pas mentir ce qui se passe
ces acclamations de ce col que de 3,2
mais qui sera peut-être plus large gamme
d ici c'est mvl bad dans ce format là
pour moi il est un peu en dessous des
joueurs dont on a parlé pas de beaucoup
un homme mais genre comme d'accord ce
qui a toujours peur de nous ouais il a
toujours perdu contre nac appui qui est
du coup tu as quand même n'a qu'à qui
est double ou tenant qui est triple
vainqueur de l'événement
basso qui est double finaliste et à carl
les deux premiers les a joués les a
gagnés en fait t'as les joueurs qui sont
tout le temps la cua régulièrement très
beau et maxime crois qu'il a une demie
contre
contre nac à ce qui est beau et il a
défaite contre sow et défaite contre et
des défaites contre nac a donc mais ok
contre sow s'est passé je réponds tout
le monde ce sont mes mais non nakache
c'est paris c'est chiant a toujours tort
comme un but cela pour dire que maxime
est quand même un peu en dessous d'eux
même si on adore maxime ou quoi on doit
faire preuve d'objectivité les résultats
parlent et encore une fois on parle bien
de ce format dans ce truc là en blitz
sur internet la ctu parlons beats sur
l'échiquier je vais maxime leroux dessus
quoi en tout cas un minimum au même
niveau
tu parles de maxime en longues il boxe
quatre catégories au dessus des 10 cars
où il ya même pas de match en fait c'est
ça n'est pas une discussion en fait on
ne parle même pas mais dans ce format
précis je le trouve un peu en dessous
après mac à moi je les ai vus friable
aux championnats des états unis
je le vois pas en finale steinbach a
même chanté c'était quoi la cadence
tu sais plus c'est long non pas plus ou
moins partie lente c'était ok 4,5
deviennent aux as et donc avec les
blancs il est vraiment parti bon après
il a il a joué 4 me fascine ou quoi mais
il est parti pour des petits systèmes
partout un bon jeu suite à plusieurs
choix de gêne à quel point le 4 c'est
jouable mais émettra qui joue c'est ce
truc là ça c'est bien mais en fait
qu'ils aient pris quatre c'est dommage 5
le coût qui est des six four b3 à ça ça
va tu peux faire ce que tu veux mais
foulée 3 tu fout le bordel et en fait
d'ailleurs avec les noirs c'est mieux de
filer aux 5
parce qu'en fait je faire calisesi
sportaccord champions ouais mais tu
conserves des cahiers b5 des trucs
attendu g6 d'un f3 web on trouve ça bien
sûr
said c'est de dévier d'un étroit tueur
et iter le même machin tu as quel écran
qu'il y ait de prendre donc ils doivent
faire simple je suis dam des cinq
leaders cartable s'être arrêté vraiment
rôle ou là et tu veux les gagner en
qualité
mais quoique c'est que tu es mal
développée donc appris à traire dp6
machin qui est les catalans fait froid
que d'après leur dit c'est bien pour les
blancs mais qu'on pratique se passe ici
non il n'a pas du tout fait ça si l'on
fait baca il est ici s'il a pris mais en
fait vous avez 3 tu peux aussi
simplement ne pas faire payer ces six et
un ans que je montrais way est ok bon je
veux dire c'est votre égal ça mais
pareil c'est parti technique cartel mais
j'aime bien ça martins aimar en fait il
part du principe qu'il est content de
juste égaliser je vois un truc très
technique et il se dit juge je joue
mieux aux échecs que tout en fait il se
dit j'ai une meilleure technique que toi
je vais je vais te marcher dessus quoi
je vais trouver tu vas en plus si jamais
il se sent fatigué je pensais ce qui a
nui à faire qui est moins de trucs à
calculer après étonnamment la partie
d'avant c'est lui qui a planté la
tactique etc est le 5e très facilement
guéri ouais mais après il n'a pas réussi
à vraiment mettre la pression dans un
truc où il était gagnant il a laissé le
cavalier des six qui gagne en un pour
guérir paris la pâte est clean un nom à
la pâte et q mais non mais du coup c'est
mieux que je le truc comme ça en compte
ou la partie d'avant là où il jouait
pour attaquer le pion des six mois qu'il
a bouffé d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression
que ça ne lui convenir genre de partie
et puis là il mène d'un point locaux
pire se joue ce fait des nuls bah c'est
pas grave vous des trois cavaliers f5
il se passe rien même étaient heureux
qui se passe rien métier que moi aussi
j'ai ce style même si le quarté nièvre
gaëtan bille soir là je suis très
heureux avec les blancs enfin je te dis
tout de suite je vais faire un petit fou
d'être one piece flancs des deux camps
je peux attaquer rangée de fâcher
heureux quoi enfin je suis heureux de
tout mon petit à quatre double un peu
mes tours pas j'adore quoi je bouge un
peu mes pièces ce que me disait de
lecointe
j'adorais quoi mais oui non ils bougent
l'occasion les pièces j'adore ce
compliment quand genre il ya les pièces
qui veut et bouge très bien et dégage
mais en fait il est pas mal ce
compliment c'est de dire le gars qui
aime bien jouer quand il se passe rien
comme un tube
hyest est heureux quoi déjà revenir une
fois je constate avec lui j'ai ouï bon
vallée vont quand même faire nul non
détrompe toi il aime bien bouger les
pièces où il s'est vraiment fait le
grill à bouger les pièces ont enfin cook
enfin quand même mais attention il fait
avaler f5 qui se met le pion à f5 pour
bloquer le cavalier a failli ouais moi
aussi j'adore j'aime bien ce style qui
va peut-être conduit longtemps réussite
tu dis oui bon bah faisait bien en fait
où je les pièces de choix mais ça assez
rouscoff non comme un style ouais des
mets bien rien faire et comme ça oui mon
nom change pas après j'ai enfoncé plus
pour plus vieilli non non je suis encore
un peu jeune pour enfin je veux dire
quand tu vas pas le soleil de l'année tu
vieillis vite
c'est ça aussi je crois qu'à 40 châtié
qu'à cette époque en sibérie avait deux
heures de soleil par jour mais j'ai vu
il disait de tourner sur le mois de
décembre 3,3 jours durée d'une journée 7
heures soit à 21h01 mais ces terrils et
en plus il fait mauvais et je peux te
dire qu en réussite en ce sens que si
elle est très bas quand il fait mauvais
comme ça à moscou je te jure que des
fois il ya des mois de janvier j'ai
vraiment peut-être pas vu le soleil
pendant un mois mais genre il ya des
nuages très épais du matin au soir enfin
oui tu vois jamais le soleil pourquoi
les buts locaux
oui tu vois d'autres choses très
important bon par contre à faire [ __ ]
un f6 ça va être bien nul 1 voix pas
faim c'est peut-être pas obligé mais oui
enfin si tu veux faire nul qui fait ça
peut-être fait tour j'ai un bateau ce
qui fait que ça tourne en rond c'est pas
grave c'est cool ces trois là il se
passe rien ça génial
un tour au toit était changée tous
rejetés reconduit pions et c'est génial
peut être que tu fais rien quoi tu es là
elle échoue à quatre portes et options
bon tu prends à tu finis le pion en
parle plus elle est nulle et gris qui
propose ça aurait été beau de pas
accepter non je la joue dégage
j'aime bien bouger les pièces quoi le
lait il aurait joué comme je le voulais
un peu les pièces je suis là je sors un
peu l'orangé 4 la bourse américaine et
que 16 on va faire quoi fumer quatre
dans les six petites ventes n'ont cessé
5 qui avait trois attaques trop tard
potter
je pensais que carlson peut perdre s'ils
jouent comme nancy carlsen joue au
niveau qu'il a joué contre eux par hamla
contre n'importe lequel des deux est
gagne facilement en fait c'est pas
possible en fait bon j'ai pas sujet de
match peut pâtir mais le truc c'est karl
scène s'il est à son meilleur
passez juste union mondiale quoi donc
par définition pas évident d'aller
chercher après sur un match de quatre
heures et ont bien sûr mais tombe bien
sûr c'est pas s'ils ont donc il ya quel
moyen de retourner le truc hein qu'est
ce que 0 sur courrier une partie non
c'est pas sûr d'être 01 sais rien mais
forcément sur le dessus puis tu essayes
de gracia c'est même sûr que tu gagneras
pas mon avis fabre 0,1 simek joue bien
en face nabeul
non mais zorro sein à partir de 0,5
s'impose déjà tracé 0/30 c'est un peu un
peu consistants et je crois que c'est
gagnant à partir de 08 1 n'ont
généralement pas dans toutes les
positions évidemment mais ça commence à
être dans le règne de bon ok puis sainte
est vraiment bien impulse avion ça va
dépendre puis 5 à rabat et +14 us ça se
passe très bien tu par l'espagne en la
poussant quatre heures la presse répond
que le genre pression c'est si c'est une
position normale août à +1 tu avec l'été
mec si t'as plus simple si besoin de
recomposer une estonienne ou quoi
rien n'est fait c'est compliqué de gens
pratiquent d'ailleurs à partir de
puissance un canton dire plus ainsi mco
quoi déjà tu commence déjà à dire t'as
décimales en espagnol c'est très heureux
maxime est dans son road à 3 858 mal
contre hikaru america roux est ce qu'on
disait à juste avant et il est
impressionnant quand même rien à faire
higuain qui donc il faut prouver 3 ça se
regarde entre que toujours regarder mais
en fait ça n'apporte pas grand chose et
enlève un cavalier qui fait rien tu te
sépare de la paire de fou alors certes
abymes à peu la structure mais tu vas
avoir du mal à attaquer sachant qu'en
plus pas mal ça le foot le foot cases
blanches des blancs viendra ans les
quatre donc tu t'es de patron c'est fini
ça fait joli thématiques 1 ça arrive
souvent dans mes genre de scandinaves ou
quoi ça arrive souvent
il y en a qu à ce bug a battu l'as déjà
gagné plus ou moins en fait pas de route
a provoqué à 4 les blancs ils vont pas
faire ces trois facilement tuer michael
bay 3 mais là le truc lequel vous montre
qu'il est pensé de ce très fort saganne
tout de suite enfin je vois pas de
défense après l'état des carnets dé
sinko des trucs comme ça
ok montpon d'échangeurs verts de quatre
ou mais je pense qu'elle et ses 2 c'est
un peu un pion non mais là si le vois
pas un problème parce que ça c'est quand
même plus que dans leurs cordes
juste les affiches beaucoup oui en fait
c'est plus facile à louper pour geeks et
les blancs qui regardent le passe coque
femme suzy wepad match qu'on fout
échouage 4 h 5 de noter que dans l'autre
sens tarbes
mais elle attend et ce que y'a des fous
h 4 15 juges sur tout le monde parce que
maintenant quand je prends si c'est bon
ça non non ce ramdam c'est un toit sont
floues les trois hommes proches 6
c'est pas très impressionnant ouais vas
tu es content parce que même si vous les
bonnes questions est intacte on l'a vu
c'était sûr qu'il le verrait mais là
encore un c c'est vraiment des grosses
fautes femmes dans cette grille
tactiquement a peur de toi tu t'es comme
ceux visant à ce niveau là une nouvelle
fois comprenons nous bien nous on fait
des fautes comme ça à toutes les parties
on ne vit que pour faire des fautes
comme sa mère et leur niveau c'est des
grosses fautes en femme
c'était bien je ne lisais pas dramatique
en fait le truc c'est que tu es tu vas
encore joué mais de pas voir ça c'est un
peu comme la partie d'avancé quand m ta
quasiment de la chance d'être encore
dans la game
je suis tu mérite d'avoir déjà perdu
quasiment quand tu étais très chanceuse
en fait tu vois pas si tu es arrivé
parmi eux qui se trouvent ses bronzes
pas si grave en fait ben c'est un peu
par miracle ça joueur qui a pris mon
pseudo qui nous dit qu'ils agressent à
chardonne bienvenus il est très sauvage
en fait qu'un seul match à un autre gars
encore plus on sait pas on sait pas son
pseudo ce que fait prendre book mais
clairement dessous tactiquement pas
rapide pas intuitif pour 8 ou ça qu'il
veut tout contrôler car elle n'a pas
confiance en lui quand c'est le bordel à
il a pas confiance à un manque de
confiance énorme
et pourtant tu joueur le plus gros trash
talker du truc qui fait le malin tout le
temps et c'était une fête devait être
tout temps le malin en fait ne pas avoir
aucune confiance comme ça peut-être
c'est pour ça qu'il faut autant le main
me dit qu'ils avaient des 5 intéressant
wayne en mission il faut partir sur le
caïd et 5 mais bon puisqu'il écope
mouais voir qu'il ya des cadres direct
du dj qui s'appelle être pleutre c'est
pas faux à ton avis contraintes du top
1000 mg et du top 10 il ya beaucoup de
différences de niveau aa oui à 40
millions de galaxy 1
beaucoup de différence ce n'est pas ils
vont pas gagne à 100% mais ils vont
guère face tu fais un match en 10
parties c'est être un gros score 8 2
trucs comme ça
bonjour j'aimerais commencer les échecs
je peux commencer par où je connais
vraiment rien mais coup tu peux
commencer par toucher à ce point comme
où t'as plein de leçons c'est hyper
interactif et tu peux jouer et tu peux
suivre la chaîne bitstream sur youtube
où il ya tout un tas de vidéos pour pour
les débutants pour bien commencer les
parties donc tu as plusieurs plateformes
sur lesquelles tu peux te renseigner en
toute détente fab loi et puis après
votre couvert des parties puis tu vois
cette plaie ce thème bien jouer et puis
après bas plus ça va plus pour essayer
de faire plus mais déjà pour commencer
c'est super si être pratique avec
internet c'est que ouais t'as des
plateformes voilà comme chez ce point
comme tu peux jouer dessus
c'est gratuit et n'a pas besoin d'aller
dans un club je sais papa surtout là on
parle de confidente récents cpie de vue
et et voilà tu côte est et tu verras en
plus à une semaine la semaine maintenant
gratuite avec chasse câm tu peux avoir
le diamant pendant une semaine
gratuitement pour bientôt tester pour
être bien sûr bien sûr c'est presque une
semaine 16 h
je ne pense pas ok ils venaient mais il
veut mettre 6 7 5 est quelque chose qui
signe que peut-être même où ouais tu
souhaites soit je sais pas de quel est
ce qu'on peut faire pour eux huit aussi
bon au moins c'est bien demander si
jamais un listing aux anathèmes quattro
contrôler la case g3 de la tour donc
l'attention et maintenant le flou b3 et
d'attac la tournée on veut prendre
pouvait pas prendre le coup d'avant te
tue montré pourquoi il faut s'écarter
chèque
wall street sera à oui ok on ne veut pas
prendre de coups d'avancé puisque les
tours j'ai trois matches de mort fitch
croit s'appelle sa jolie coincé à plat
pas de casse de fuite peu de pièces pour
intercepter rien et donc f5 l'idée c'est
de pouvoir sur des cases pour le roi
pour partir soit vers le centre soit que
la tour défendre l' akazu le faisait
maintenant agissons pour aimer à roye et
suite ici et on n'y a plus de ça la
petite histoire il a fait autour des 2
ouais ben tura 8 d'accor bien joué l'aca
un gros pions de plus pour artemiev
parce que non seulement donc il a ce
pion plus qu'il a gagné mais en plus il
a une activité de folie un sur sur
l'échiquier avec les tours les fous le
roi blanc qui peut être faible avec des
matchs sur la première rangée qui
peuvent arriver s'accumulent les trucs
tu as tu sais si c'est puis empruntent
maintenant je pensais mais ce 6e titre
que je vais dire des ouvertures prend
des six salariés un fou c'est ça gagne
notre père très bon ses sept tours 17
j'ai toussé 5 du coût mais si c'est si
cette envie de faire un pas tous tu
verras secondes pour guerrier ça
pourrait être le premier break du match
finalement fab cas ils essayent donc
pousser ça qu'on ait pensé veilleux fait
retour j'ai trois genres c'est ça mais
bon croit suite et surtout et si tu
prends tu t'en fiches logique ça paraît
assez logique
en tout cas c'est bien aigri il essaye
et de ne peut rendre la pression
bordélique vu qu'ils étaient très mal et
de pousser l'adversaire à la faute après
j'imagine que sur un jeu parfois des
narces il n'a pas trop l'air d'espoir
pour la pour guérir on va voir
j'ai poussé cette du coup sûrement il
voulait avoir la tour j'ai trois en
l'air dans la parlotte dont tu parlais
tout à l'heure il faut j'aime bien
besoin stabilise
ouais c'est bien bulle dorée demande
pourquoi f500 pêche le match mais en
fait tu vois ta touré fuite voulaient
bloquer par le pion à vii
elle est une liberté devant m avec les
cloches et donc le chou moderat m la
tchèque 3 dans le coin tu prends juste
le boucher ouais c'était ça la grosse
différence commencer chacun plus de 30
ans et devenir grand maître c'est
possible à écoute peut-être après je
sais pas s'il ya quelqu'un à déjà a déjà
réussi cet exploit mais j'ai pas envie
de dire que c'est impossible parce que
pourquoi pas en fait
mais bon tu pars pas favori mais battu
pour obtenir un tupperware être un très
bon joueur d'échecs 120 grand maître a
pas une obligation pour s'amuser quoi
banon mais ce qui compte c'est ça prend
du plaisir s'amuse à un type pas de
titre c'est pas très grave
prochain objectif écoute très bien dans
ce volet qui fut la grande île où ça
peut rassurer les gens me suis pas grand
maître sais pas si ça rassure les gens
mais ça va tu veux tu dis quand même
c'est pas je n'ai absolument rien à
[ __ ] en fait c'est terrible j'arrive
même pas avoir l'objectif de devient
grand maître tu as plein de monde dans
le chatt praticiens pas grand mais tout
passe et j'ai même pas l'on vit en fait
c'est bien joué là ce qui fait obstacle
aux cavaliers lassé des champions au 3e
à 6 900 cc sinko qui est la tâche est
fourché passe et le petit péroné qui
tombe et le roi qui recourent débourser
5 2 050 50 on restait hébergé tombe est
tombé 4 bof encore gagné mais c'est
gagnant mais il ya versé 4 monde tu peux
lui mettre une petite tour ici aussi
d'un bon à tant de façons tu as le temps
là tu peux tournicoter bas je pense que
les plans de ces quatre maintenant la
halle et ça fait plus de enfin pour
artemiev qui prend les devants fab
malgré ses yeux qui piquent les yeux qui
piquent et anglaise et la petite
anglaise avec les partis nés qui fait
plaisir enfin bon ça c'est ça se mérite
et quand même un petit mode danse donc
deux points d'avance franchement on va
dire les choses franchement s'il y avait
plus trop +4 ce serait pas volé en fait
je le trouve vraiment au dessus ouais
enfin voit pas on va pas on va pas
chipoter 1 le plus de et bien enfin le
moins 2 du coup pour guy et bien payé
artemiev artemiev qui est là et qui peut
être parfois tu sais quand tu es fatigué
c'est un peu comme au foot des fois
quand à une équipe qui est fatigués ils
sont mauvais au début et à la fin c'est
en jouant les dix premières minutes ils
ont du mal à rentrer dans le match
ces choses là la façon de fumer tue
hyatt à toute une période date entre la
15e et la 80e minute où ils sont bien
quoi ces pages pas si tu as raté le
décrassage avec un peu dur et la fin si
c'est ça sourira t ma faim
la cour a en fait pression ces gens même
si à l'inversé pas complètement la même
question c'est quand que tu la passion
des échecs
moi je pense petit vers 7 ans et toi
bats je pense petit aussi faso sur sept
mois c'est mon père qui m'a appris quand
j'étais tout petit il m'a mené au club
avec lui tout ça je serai que j'aimais
bien je vous hais les magazines tout
dans ma chambre
jouer contre leur dit c'est vite en fait
tailler les posters de vlad dans la
chambre et ou pas je crois que j'ai pas
de poster je retrouve mes vieilles
photos jours à quoi ressemble la chambre
quand j'étais petit je pourrais vous
dire est ce que tu as un peu perdu cette
passion avec le temps en fait oui enfin
j'ai plus d'échecs 47 son métier pas
mais je crois que c'est plus ont joué à
l'époque c'était un jouet neuf doigts
j'aime bien c'est bon en jouer sans
jouer je m'attends à rien de jouer de
joie jovial de joux quoi j'ai pas fait
dresser un mot qui pue positivisme
maintenant énorme choses positives dans
le mot en fait c est fou à l'époque de
10 blu j'avais des posters de 10 bouffe
ou trois matches c'est le drapeau de
l'arménie c'est le drapeau de l'arménie
sur les murs quoi mais dans le moment
toujours bien le tournage très content
pour comprendre ça à tous mais mais fait
ça ne dérange pas de ne pas jouer quand
j'étais petit je voulais faire que jouer
quoi et les voilà mais enfin je prends
toujours le même plaisir à lire des
livres des chèques afin de choses comme
ça mais j'ai tellement à la rage en fait
de la compétition gagner des parties je
m'en fous un peu vain j'ai plus rien à
prouver que je sens
j'irai pas beaucoup plus haut que ce que
j'ai fait je sais pas trop à la raison
fondamentale mais mais je penche
peut-être plus lents dans la
transmission des choses comme ça que de
jouer pour gagner tout le temps toujours
quoi il aurait été plus trop dans le
vent la compétition on va dire ça comme
ça
ouais vraiment quand je joue je n'ai pas
envie de perdre quand même face c'est
clair mais bon tu vois on veut faire des
petites nul et ça me va quoi ça ne
m'étonne pas j'ai piqué loge plaisir à
ces super plaisir j'ai 36 ans mais oui
non mais c'est normal après façon assez
tu fait un peu le tour de la compétition
mise à part ceux qui sont vraiment dans
le top mondial et qui continue à avoir
des chances de gagner des gros titres ou
quoi après tu la compétition on aime
bien mais tu perds tu t'en fais quand
même le tournant au final web et sur moi
après tu as des gens tous plus
compositeur que d'autres par nature mais
ouais tu vois ça je fais le tour après
j'aime bien quand même jeu en tournoi
voir des gens que j'aime bien voyager
c'est plus ça mais moteur en fait que
d'aller jouer à tourner pour pour le
gagner en soi non mais c'est plus les à
côtés qui me font plus plaisir que je
pense je pense que c'est assez c'est
assez commun à beaucoup de deux sportifs
qui ont fait du haut niveau et qui à un
moment donné en ont peut-être pas marre
mais qui n'ont plus la grinta de leurs
20 ans c'est normal ne sont pas contents
de bouger les pièces vraiment eu
il bouge bien les pièces tu sais il a
mal à ses beaux que tutu des faits
l'échiquier tu arrives et les finales
sans fruits sur le départ c'est très
heureux quoi
d'amd de mon écoute la position de
tracer également talent pions détroit un
peu faible mais c'est rien non non ça on
se rue s'équilibraient on fait du
probable de partout ils bougent les
pièces et ça c'est un peu le style
d'arte msf après samuel terrain artemiev
entre guillemets c'est devenu grand
maître à calage fab
je crois à 25 ou 26 choot hamel je crois
que c'est 25 ans donc tard pour inscrire
d'autres sont capables de faire ça tu as
des navettes de m treize ans maintenant
14 ans c'est pas le commingeois les tous
meilleurs ont souvent ils ont du mal
après veut pas jouer mais mais voilà est
il forcément on était déjà fort jeunes
au p 0,4 0,5 watt réponse d'apple former
les meilleurs de ma catégorie d'âge
en france on a fait des championnats
jeunes internationaux je fais d'europe
et du monde des choses comme ça ouais
ouais forcément après un maison en été
on était dans les bons mais pas dans les
tous meilleurs non plus quoi bah ouais
ce sens et généralement un truc comme
les échecs en fait pour vraiment faire
partie un jour du top 100 mondial et
rentrer et était forcément dans les
quatre cinq meilleurs de sa catégorie
d'âge qui n'était pas notre cas on était
un poil derrière pas très loin mais un
poil derrière non nos chemins du monde
ouais bah ouais baup ont joué j'avais
des mecs comme job à votre stock était
déjà plus forte puisque j on était un
peu on n'était pas dans les trois quatre
meilleurs n'aide pas les favoris des des
championnats du monde quoi non non pas
du tout loin d'être favoris mais moi je
crois mrdja les résultats que j'ai fait
je fais en calcat aux riches avaient
fait 18 en championnat du monde et je me
rappelle que j'avais bien battu mont
mon lots en fait tu à surperformer ouais
surperformer et un championnat d'europe
aussi j'étais bien mais tu vas même en
jouant super bien on était en super
forme je me menacer le top 10 j'ai raté
une game contre romanov une finale
depuis à la con et après j'ai dû faire
13 peut-être tu vois 13e est ok mais
j'avais fait que des perfs à toutes les
parties face c'était fou mais c'est pas
terrible
enfin un toit solaire s'arrête atout
énorme et je serai bien mais oui mais
oui mais ça des données ouais champion
du monde a tout donné et a plutôt
c'était plutôt favorable en gros sur les
scénarios de partie était que 13e place
et c'est un peu chiant quoi mais pressé
ça c'est pas grave ça nous a pas
empêchés de continuer à jouer mais que
je comprends vite sera pas champion du
monde
batta un peu loin en fait ouais mais
après en avoir de continuer à s'amuser
même sans être son tour du monde
sinon y'a plus grande qui joue aux
échecs détient martirossian qui a été
champion du monde - de 14 ou quoi
finalement longue il est voilée 26-20
donc of faut déjà être un vrai bon faut
être dans les meilleurs jeunes et encore
après réussir à percer quoi c'est
vraiment très difficile
c'est ça oui bah ça ne veut rien dire
enfin c'est bien c'est déjà fait une
condition sinequanone des efforts en
chaîne mais pas suffisante pour devenir
fort plus tard oui c'est ça c'est vrai
ça te place pour peut-être menacé un
jour d'être formé c'est une menace
d'être fort en fait voilà c'est ça après
voilà grand matin plus de 2600 tu es
déjà peut-être [ __ ] à charlo mais t'es
pas dans l'élite mondiale non plus mais
maximois il était bien au dessus quand
il était gamin lui justement il était
dans les premières places de ces
championnats du monde jeunes etc
il va donner dans les tout meilleurs il
était grand mais tu as 15 ans max alors
je sais pas exactement on a eu quinze
saisons c'est sûr
oui donc quand tu es déjà grands maîtres
à 15 16 ans quoi et tu menaces de
menacer quoi balle puis puis l'a28 pain
vous voyez quitté depuis les vitres tout
ça il est d'un style de jeu vers l'avant
[Musique]
c'était pas un jouet à rome gaccio n'en
est impression 13 ans j'aime max je
m'excite etienne à 13 ans avec max avait
fait un peu plus tard oui je pense aussi
mais aucune preuve et rires oui j'ai pas
la fiche wikipédia sous les yeux donc je
fais c'est un peu de mémoire
les 13 ans consistent pas pour maxime ce
que je pense que j'ai fait at on affirmé
anna uci ce club je puisse te en 2004
2005 et date mais il dépend remettre du
quand il était en tournée
donc il voulait devenir grand maître
donc toute façon c'était plus tard que
ses 13 ans trop vide en soi même et baky
russie était vraiment impressionnant
quand ils étaient jeunes afin qu'ils les
aient grande maturité dans le jeu en
fait d'y jouer à l'arthémuse quoi déjà
wen en bas qui est impressionnant mais
donc du coup oui donc du coup nous on
était bons jeunes mais si on se compare
à eux on était très nul quoi voilà on
est à un étage de la fusée d'être dans
les meilleurs quoi on était en l'état
juste en dessous mais j'ai retrouvé des
vieux papiers
en fait quand tu vas te souviens de
contrer des petits recevait des cours à
faire avec des exercices
ouais en fait je te deuxième lots
d'ailleurs baky dans les maquis recevait
les cours at c'était bien ouais mais
bakhit j'arrêtais déjà 10 900 quelque
chose moi j'étais 16 cents
il est déjà d un gap quoi ouais c'est
sûr et puis le gap va encore amplifier
très vite bon je reste là 700 et et 2002
puis me permettre
enfin non mais oui il était
impressionnant fins et baky c'est une
fusée 1
comme tout bon alors cette partie du
coup on est parti sur un sujet
intéressant pour les pour les échecs
pour les nouveaux hélas cette finale ses
pions de plus pour arte
ça va ressembler à ce qu'on a déjà vu
ouais y'a le pion âge qui part elle est
gagnable à mon avis tour f 5 voix et du
monte d'un cran
j'ai ce qu'on peut plus retour de 105
ouais mais je pense avec si peu de temps
à la pendule tu fais pas en fait ce que
tu peux perdre aussi mais en fait je ne
sais pas trop ce tour je pose la
question je t'aime pas sûr de moi c'est
un tout qui se regardent pas ce que tu
te ramasses aux autres finales droite
qui ont pas s'éloigner étudie aspects de
coup l'a atteint à laquelle matt la tour
devrait être nul tu vas blocs avec le
roi et une tour des 3 3 attends attends
quand même il boit trop dire ce qu'on
veut être sûr amener leurs ouailles
perrinon ça allait trop vite une
nouvelle nul nombreux nuls wemmel
artémias je pense que dans avec un peu
plus de temps où notre condition de
match il aurait peut-être tenté le tour
des cinq mais là avec peu de temps la
peur de se faire retourner de la perdre
carrément il a voulu assurer bah oui la
puce deux essais c'est la pause là ouais
c'est la pause et merci à mic mac made
man qui dit je viens du stream de
domingo je trouve ça ou ce que tu fais
avec lui sky sardou il pensait ça fait
grandir la commune c'est toujours cool à
regarder bah écoute ça fait c'est
bientôt dix ans qu'on fait ça ma demande
c'est de faire grandir la commune des
échecs juste là ça a pris une tournure
vous ça va beaucoup plus vite en trois
semaines va y avoir plus de gens qui
vont venir en trois semaines qu'en dix
ans mais oui mais c'est grâce à la série
et au confinement
là ils ont été obligés l'itu qui
montrent que les membres du now en fait
non non j'ai pété membres mais j'ai fait
plusieurs tours dans la bas donc le naos
est un club à paris qui a pas duré très
longtemps mais qui était tenue par la
présence était et est milliardaire et
donc elle a investi pour faire un super
club à paris dans des très beaux locaux
dans des champions d'europe surtout de
france chaque année et ils ont pu former
des jeunes
voilà sa durée de trois ans en fait et
ils ont rusé détournant bas je crois pas
que c'était très longtemps en fait non
mais je te fais confiance parce que
c'était un peu plus âgés que moi donc tu
as
plus connu le truc quoi ouais j'ai 18
novembre
maintenant peut-être qu'elle a duré
quatre ans je sais pas trop mais ça n'a
pas duré bien peu 1 4 ans je pense c max
ouais c'était gros club mais pour a
demandé à amazon depuis je trouve jouer
là-bas il y en a déjà parlé mais on lui
demandera après on leur demandera après
ils nous en reparlera un petit peu et ce
qui va être à deux doigts des 2850 ce
soir je pense toujours à dos d'un parti
mais elle va faire une micro sieste info
russe ça ça marche super bien les micro
sieste moi quand j'ai eu ma pas si
courte carrière de joueur de poker
les micro sieste dans les sessions de 11
12 heures je les ai utilisés et je te
jure que les pièces de deux minutes
puisque tu as vraiment genres entre 55
et et du coup tu fais des sièges de deux
minutes ça t'aide mais un truc de ouf
en fait je pense que si tu étais fatigué
tu reviens à ton état de fatigue de
l'art d'avant en fait jamais essayé mais
ouais j'ai entendu pas mal de biens du
grossier et en fait il ya une méthode
marrant tu prends une cuillère et tu
dors en fait quand tu t'endors tard
relâchement musculaire
bon bah du coup tu échappes la cuillère
qui tombe par terre ligne et ça te
réveilles tempo et voilà après il faut
réussir à très vite la con moi j'avais
cinq minutes pour réussir à très vite
sans dormir donc c'est musique de
relaxation un tout petit peu avant qu'on
commence à te mettre dans le rythme puis
tu mets la nuit tu prépares ton réveil
bien évidemment à l'avance tu les a tous
préparés en fait comme ça t'as rien à
faire et utah longe et essaye de se
caler sur la musique et moi boudant -
avec l'expérience réussissent à
m'endormir en retz en deux trois minutes
et tu dors deux minutes mais ça te fait
un bien mais c'est impressionnant le
projet cette fois je suis tue trop pris
pour faire la sieste mais ça ferait du
bien de dormir un peu bas parce que j'en
ai fait une avant le stream je fais une
sieste de 3 4 minutes ce que j'avais
trop de trucs à faire
j'imagine même pas en fait depuis que je
t'appelais de thaler il ya encore
d'autres trucs reims et c'est en fait
j'ai su que mon téléphone n'arrête pas
de sonner avec des propositions
intéressantes c'est impressionnant pour
mieux c'est mieux c'est que dès que de
la merde son téléphone non en fait à que
des gens qui proposent des trucs
intéressants et tout mais donc
donc j'ai pu faire j'ai eu que quelques
minutes pour faire la sieste mais tu as
deux trois quatre minutes elle met bien
à tenir quoi tu l'as où vincent quoique
je les fait depuis vendredi avec qui
pensent s est pas mal je pense tu seras
dans le chat non vendredi ça va être
cool ouais y penser ça va être cool et
il a quel niveau du cou des chefs écoute
il a entre 900 et 1000 en blitz et ça ne
l'intéresse pas durant 10 minutes et
aucun intérêt il veut jouer vite i
believe s'ils envoient les coups ils
aiment bouger les pièces que c'est un
buteur dans l'âme
ok ça fait plaisir mais tu es là cette
curiosité pas vraiment de progresser
enfin si aussi mais surtout de
comprendre en fait il a la curiosité de
comprendre sage et parle un peu du
système de long du développement de
tallard et tout était super content
quand même mais c'est super intéressant
et tout il a cette envie tu vas de voir
comment ça marche quoi c'est bien que
son chat comprendre les concepts aux
échecs les réutiliser un doux de
position un peu similaire c'est le début
d'un truc des échecs ça marche beaucoup
par reconnaissance tout pattern en fait
une fois que tu laisses pote tu sens
qu'il ya potentiellement un truc à faire
que tu as déjà vu
tu connais et donc ça t'aide way et
domine bellakhal niveau je crois qu'il
ya autour de 1000 1100 domingo mais je
sais pas domingo je sais pas le mieux
étant quelqu'un de très près c'est quand
je lui ai parlé ce matin il m'a dit gros
via pop corn soir on voit mercredi quoi
mais ça se voit dans les stream que
que domingo c'est quelqu'un de très
perfectionniste en fait moi pour faire
pas mal de ce crime aussi ça devrait te
connais super bien ses sujets et qui
doit beaucoup les bosses et en amont il
faut enfin je sais pas je vois un moment
si tu veux que ça marche ce que tu fais
faut avoir envie de bien faire les
choses
peu à faire à larache n'importe quoi ah
bah c'est pas pour rien mais qu'il a un
stream qui marche aussi bien qu'il a des
émissions aussi bien c'est qu'il ya du
boulot derrière la mediapad pas de
hasard
enfin un truc qui marche i cube le
tableau pistonné tant que tu veux faire
ce que tu veux si du caca ça sera du kk
je te confirme tu fais tu puisses te
tais autant que tu veux ça ça à part
gêner ceux qui travaillent mais sinon ça
sert pas à grand chose donc le clavier
jouer trois parties contre bruce il ya
deux ans quand tu en avais fait
s'illustra graphiste à cette époque
résultat deux défaites une victoire
terrible donc brewster d'envoyer tout
quoi oui j'ai senti quite façon il m'a
dit soit ça se passe très bien ça se
passe très mal
en fait il envoie all-in et puis way est
très chaud quoi mais jamais un seul sens
l'esprit de quelqu'un qui a envie de
s'amuser et qui m'a il est vraiment très
très très cool en plus vieux ont
peut-être un jour on verra gaël mais il
va avoir du niveau il veut servir l'a6
avant de jouer je savais avant de venir
jouer la cie est quoi cette terrible et
gally l'avenir il va jouer l'acier
servir la cuillère son intérêt spot
qu'elle va venir il sera 2005
alors qu'est ce que je vais apprendre
tout le monde y va les retourner
il écoute il est cool a alors ça va
bientôt reprendre les gars arrivent à
avoir une heure 1/2 3 + 1 donc ce avec
une cadence un peu plus rapide
ça va enchaîner je vois un peu sur
twitter ce qui se passe bel endroit
twitter le live avec domingo ça est
tellement le feu mercredi
j'imagine même pas en fait c'est
tellement un bon switcher à la domingo
c'est fou et comment ça se passe où sri
mohd aux endroits où je sais pas encore
j'ai pas ultra cheap c'est terrible mais
c'est juste et son invité chez lui et
voilà les deux vont tenir et qui pense
et je sers équipe en souviendrez tout ça
non c'est tellement plaisir domingo de
alors la chance de faire des échecs avec
lui puis en plus il va donner une grosse
visibilité au jeu donc ça fait super
plaisir tu vois quand à des gens comme
comme domingos ardoz peut-être étoiles
qui va s'y remettre j'espère je sais pas
il pense et c'est qu'ils se mettent aux
échecs ça fait vraiment parler du jeu
c'est bien
ah bah bien sûr pas ce n'est que positif
pour imposer des chèques n'a rien à dire
c'est très cool donc les chasses à
reprendre
il a pas une commune trash en plus
domingo non non il a une bonne comme il
est vrai avoir moi je trouve ça un
streamer vraiment abdominaux j'adore ce
qu'il fait mais intimiste arrivé aurait
été ça aurait été magnifique aux échecs
bas le truc en fait c'est que si les
échecs ça commence vraiment à prendre
sur twitch après que c'est toujours
pareil quand à un jeu qui marche
beaucoup s'ils ont réussi à mettre les
échecs en top 10 régulièrement sur toute
une année on peut voir plein de gros
switcher il jouait pas ce qu'ils auront
peut-être envie de l'essayer s'il voit
tout le monde aime quoi tu dis bon
hockey et si ça plaît à tout le monde
sait que c'est bien je sais pas ce que
tu en penses fable mais moi je vois les
choses comme ça faute de quoi et ça
repart allez c'est reparti à retenir
fait les noirs
et que si elle nous faire un petit
écossaise à nouveau donc il a changé ou
bep cap cette fois le trouble et 6 donc
l'idée tu perds un terme et a provoqué
ces trois donc il a mis le pion là bas
ça prend la caisse du cavalier des sacs
est naturel pour revenir vers l'avant
poste en dessins souvent ce qu'on fait
c'est ces quatre cavaliers ces trois là
pour faire des taux de marc auxi et de
placer quand même 11 et ouais mais je
fais exprès de pas trop bronzé sert je
fais un peu ce que je peux je me cache
du soleil parce que je suis un peu trop
pâle et ça peut vite virer au rouge
s'est vite mal se passait mal soit là
c'est s'inquiète pas donc je suis super
vigilant troubles tu as bien raison tu
as bien raison de soleil peut être
bénéfique mais aussi dangereux donc
ouais dame ces deux il va essayer
d'envoyer lieu 5,6 peut aussi pour jouer
le plus rage set mais n'a pas mis la
mine dynamique car ayant b3 mais il peut
rebondir en d4 et se dire qu'il est
prend s'éprend que cela ferait plaisir
alors quand même défendre un peu le pion
aux quatre tours et à des plans et ses
fans de kelly des 4 b 4 four b2 et c est
après un jorge palmés dubé cinq c4 et
quand tu vois pas d'ailleurs
il avait trois c4 ou b2 un truc comme ça
mais quel est le sait un peu plus être
bizarre quand on le sait dehors des
trucs vers la vendée bécade est donc une
détrompe-toi fable ouais c'est un style
de jeu après un guéri c'est vrai que
autant autant je peux me retrouver dans
le style un peu plan-plan d'artemis et
ses plans plomb avec une idée autant
guéri le truc c'est qu'il a des
tellement bonne position que moi je
serai toujours là survirait tout en fait
j'ai tout le temps tout envoyer mais en
fait il ya tellement de votre vaisseau
qui veut pas les gâcher
je ne vais pas gâcher je vais faire une
passe en retrait à ces bobos il peut
faire un centre non détrompe-toi passe
en retrait de 40 mètres je garde bien le
contrôle du ballon
oui au tennis tu as une petite balmy
cours tu as envie de la taper non je
remets une petite balle bien moche on
secoue et je recule
ça y est je suis bien sur ma ligne de
fond de nouveau ça va j'avais même faire
une cloche au prochain coup faut retenir
bien défendre mon rugby fantastique quoi
il renvoie à l'arrière je sais pas il ya
un gros sur non non je vais jouer au
pied pour les stocker pour être bien sûr
de gagner du terrain quand même très
beau dans tous les sports tu veux dire
ici c'est fantastique
il se passe jamais rien quoi jeter un
oeil
je ne vais pas gâcher une si belle
action qu'elle est plutôt mieux valu à
tous oui plus d'espacé perdre au flou
oui non non il
il prend pas là ils font pas
l'adversaire à la gorge ça c'est sûr des
cinq bien joué sharp patron qui était le
plus creux suprême le pleutre original
le plan alpha on l'a guidé ses pions
prend qu'à rallier prend qu'un valet f3
et d'un prochain alors sur damas trois
il se passe quoi je suis justement pas
vu d'
il a envoyé 1 il a envoyé allez mon
petit guéridon k23 l'idée c'est que la
dame est protégé et sur qui les premiers
froids du qu'on pourra faire pions prend
vous couvrira la torah c'est quand même
de la loire il doit le voir doit le voir
alors nous juste pour dire on a une
petite est de l'ordinateur pour les
trucs tactique donc on le regarde pas
tout le temps mais quand les coûts
paraissent très trouvable dans pour leur
niveau on les dit quoi non madame e3 de
son top
mongeau a presque edf de ce si grave
mais bon pourquoi s'abaisser à sa
citadelle me 3 qui si bien mesdames f2
donc qui aurait calé f3 je prends de la
dame on va dire dame provins même état
le problème du qatar doit faire bêtement
ok il a fait d'amis g3 il n'a pas vu non
mais c'est fou non mais à un moment
donné tu peux pas faire autant de fautes
quand et top mondial
oui ça m'aide à me trompe lui céda c'est
vrai on peut dire que c'est un truc
corner ouais non franchement pourquoi tu
joues c'est terrible de pas voir ces
trucs là c'est quand même sympa au moins
on est sûr qu'ils trichent pas à dire
non mais là je veux dire au bout d'un
moment oui là c'est naturel c'est très
naturel et que tellement nul qu'on dit
quand tu peux m'étendre ta caméra toi si
tu veux jouer sans caméra parce qu'il a
pas de caméra derrière d'ailleurs guiry
là qu'une caméra lui aussi mais non mais
je veux tout même même celle là est un
c'est ce sera mieux pour tout le monde
c'est terrible non mais il rate khalfa
c'est quand même un cavalier des six
dames e3 c'est quand même que des trucs
en un an vous dans l'art de la table
trois ses plus gros raté de tous ces
mets pas tactique en fait est juste adam
attaque et a toujours caisses
disponibles dont une fois c'est bien
telle baisse de plus c'est génial je
sais même pas tactique en fait non là
c'est pas toxique est content et tu ne
veux plus te voir
ce serait beau larbi tu dis ça oui oui
et encore oui mais rappelé ici mais le
temps ouais après la position elle doit
aller quand même ce qu'il a deux a un ça
va mais bon sait rien et croit g7 f5
dale c5 ou dame existe chez pas quelque
part mais je pensais bien pris à lui en
l'air est-ce que c'est grave ce qui
menace tout être humain c'est beau ça je
peux montrer
il est joli ce math pas comment
d'ailleurs bizarrement il arrive si
souvent suis là est le problème c'est
que si tu fais surtout madame 17
il ya dans cette équipe je peux montrer
comment ce gratte et après on prend un s
être mais moi il a fait tout le cas du
coup en fait il a pas fait d'une pierre
deux coups très bien je n'ai vraiment 3g
7 et 5 et tout ça tu échanges une toux
pas à tours 3 c'est plus fort tu gagnes
un tempo sur la lame juste et maintenant
peut-être tourner un ton prend b2 à la
fin c'est fini j'aurais peut-être cinq
ans plus tard même pas d'un f1 et adam
projet 3 c'est terrible ça j'allais
pages et tour benneteau plan b 2 ça fait
mal car il menace même pas 30 du
cavalier ce qui est terrible policier
atteint 7,5 ces cinq études laissent pas
sur vous prend il ya 6 h ici c'est
surtout les sur cavani pas en b3 hockey
attaqué en fait c'est pour ce juste
pousser les pions opio la b4 des 3 3
c'est fini
et sur quel point tu veux faire petit
pion programme ont bien joué mais ok
tant des deux bébés de nos portes à
tanger deux cas il prend un quart à mes
tours des 4es et kung fu auprès des
notions messala les graphes pour guérir
parce qu'en fait tu as l'occasion de
gagner une caisse de gagnant puis ta
position
elle est difficile et tu te fais juste
défoncé non mais non ça c'est grave en
fait juste pas grave bah c'est pas grave
tu vas perdre mais mais oui pourquoi tu
joues et voilà non mes excuses de te
poser la question est ce que ça te le
dire qu'on attend ça il y à maxime ya
quelqu'un qui va jusqu'à ses blue bob il
lui a joué cette variante là mais plein
de fois et maxime a été obligé de switch
parce qu'il se faisait juste marcher
dessus
sa perte pour le monde ouais genre tout
d'un coup je pratique ériger trois food
et 3g 5h 4h 5 et maxime ont souffert
mais strasbourg vers le centre
tu te fais attaquer et gratuitement quoi
oui alors après leur tournée puisque
maxime est un magicien mais moi qui
regardais avait 11 ans les flèches et
dans l'évaluation genre dans toutes les
parties à un moment donné blue baumettes
à +3 dans tout juste c'est vrai c'est un
peu dans ce style là va tuer j'ai ici si
tu fais d'un mage 6h 4h 5 1 c'est
logique bah c'est très bien pour les
bons c'est bien pour nous ouais ouais
j'aime bien y avait une question juste
pourquoi il regagne tu t'en as pas leurs
coûts
c'est la cadence du tournoi qui veut ça
en fait c'est ils ont trois minutes là
en ce moment mais chaque coup qui jouez
et gagnez une seconde donc
donc voilà ça t'évitera de perdre à la
fin ça a quasiment plus de deux secondes
et de pouvoir faire que trois quatre ou
et bat a perdu à cause de la pendule là
au moins si tu mets une secondes par
coup à chaque fois battu maintien ta
pendule à flot la suisse a visé ces
systèmes rapporte jean ba ba ouai en
quelque sorte différent je trouve l'état
le g4 là qui était pas trop vu en fait
ouais c'est ça ce qui le font avec le g4
et rapporte moi quand j'ai joué je vais
plutôt avec un carré y en a trois et un
cavalier e de g3 mais là il le joue
comme ça il met sa ce cavalier en g3 le
caire en c3 apparaît complètement
stupide ils s'en foutent complètement
fait by le slovène rok si l'on vivait sa
bat d'ailleurs je serai bien grand quand
même un club mais c'est marrant comme
système je passe tu as déjà vu moindre
coût c'est la première fois que je
voyais autant utilisé dans le match non
mais j'ai jamais vu ce n'est qu'à la fin
j'ai déjà vu des g4 avec f3 g4 mais j'ai
quatre comme ça avec le caillou de danse
tordre de douleur
je connaissais pas vraiment intéressant
dessin qui nous voient
non les joies les joueurs ne nous
entendent pas on a les camarades et les
joueurs pour les voir et nous on
commente mais non non nous entendent pas
du tout et si on critique un peu les
coûts des joueurs on ne fait pas du tout
quand ce sont des joueurs amateurs là
c'est quand ils font des erreurs ce sont
des joueurs qui font partie du top
mondial donc on s'attend comme quand
vous regardez un match de foot
6ème bas-pays raté un contre un contre
le gardien bon ben voilà on est un peu
déçu quoi c'est un ce sont des des
joueurs qui sont tous les deux dans le
top mondial et dont on espère les
meilleurs coups tout le temps en fait
baladeur gifu pas mal de tenir le petit
système su complètement la croix bien on
va bien bon bah c'est pour défendre un
peu l'écart par l'eba présidente est un
peu dans les courants d'air mais amy est
peut-être eu 5 et des quatre bons ils
essayent oui c'est ce que je pense
tu prends des 5 etc et cinq dossiers
sous peu donc waguih qu'il prend juste
ça et belle première parce que les
blancs sont pas réglés c'est leur
attaque ils ont amassé les pièces d'un
roi mais sans créer de menaces pour
l'instant mais ils ont pas fou détroit
quoi qui serait le coup peut-être glénan
pour elle il ya trop de kate qui te
bouffe tu viens pour d4
j'ai pas trop haut pour aller dans une
qualité ci a besoin que ça pue trop ça
mais ça se passe super bien se passe
passe carrément même des cas c'est une
option d'amour ait eu en france et trois
aides alors vous le montrez juste une
montre
je vais montrer bon je le montre quand
même jean van hamme et j'ai envie de
montrer
donc là madame à deux dames b2 et
admettons qu on prend à damas deux dames
ces deux c'est juste pour illustrer
d'ailleurs ou six hockey vient de là d
un peu comme il peut bon là guy riffaud
qui enfin je sais pas s'il ya un cookie
un petit tu mets
photo ça qu'on part dit très bof f5 et
des quatre menaces la protège trois
jolies les surprend guetteront percer
des puits lecavalier il a fait cas
étaient quatre qu'est il a joué mais je
m'en vais là bas il fait des trucs beau
et bien jouer et pas facile à boire
beaucoup
l'aïe a fait une belle partie ouais
marrant c'est peut-être la partie la
plus compliquée où il a le mieux joué
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas l'occasion
d'être peloton en fait il était obligé
de jouer vers l'avant il a bien joué
mais en fait c'est un truc j'ai remarqué
et qu'en fait c'est faux pas laissé
l'occasion des jours comme ça oui ou
dans des situations pareilles
en fait face et le fameux exemple
lorsque paye tout ça c'était il ya du
monde les deux fois où qu'archos
kasparov qu'ils ont eue le must win
donc c'est à dire en fait pour ceux qui
qui connaissent pas forcément kharkov
cas ce soir c'est les deux très fort
joueur dans les années 80 début des
années 90 qui se sont jouées très
souvent en finale le champion du monde
et le règlement à l'époque ce qui jouait
24 parties donc est le meilleur après 24
parties était sacré champion du monde et
juste s'il y avait match nul 12-12 ce
qui peut arriver
c'était très serré le champion en titre
reste est champion et donc en 85
car quoi fêter encore le champion donc
match est serré et après 23 parties il
ya douze ans pour kasparov et ce jour-là
24e partie donc karpov bas il est obligé
de gagner pour conserver le titre
il a les blancs et genre en fait il fait
all in et en fait dans ce cas là
évidemment gaspard qu'il a pas de
question à se poser est l'objet de lui
aussi bas a tout donné c'est un combat
de rue et ça qu'on va ça convient mieux
à son style et il a gagné 13 ans voilà
et deux ans plus tard en 87 ils ont le
même cas de figure inversée donc de
bucaspor les champions du monde car pas
fait donc challenger et la 12e foire
karpov avant la dernière et là que ce
prof qui pourtant tout incitera à penser
qu'il va juste jouer pour l'attaqué à
tout va
parce qu'il doit absolument gagner bah
pour le coup donc il a joué une partie
assez tranquille comme a peur tpf a joué
des coups se placer et car potes
voulaient tellement à faire que nul ne
pensait pas du tout essayé de gagner
parce que nul suffisait pour gagner le
match que dès qu'il y avait des coups un
peu des quatre filles auraient pouvait
prendre un petit risque mais que ça
semble être le point indiqué zidane ont
surtout pas je verrai contrôle
je regardais contrôle je vous garde le
contrôle est là comment se faire une
petite concession par ci une petite
concession par là et perdre cette partie
est donc dans la proche c'est peut-être
mieux de ne pas forcer l'adversaire à
jouer son meilleur en étant forcé de
trouver les seuls coûts et être à la
guerre mais justement le
psychologiquement c'est pas évident si
justement le gap a une tendance à
chercher sa de justement pas le forcer
qui va rester un peu à jouer semi
pleutre n'a pas le forcer à jouer le bon
coup quoi attirer les bons coups baroin
qui l'a 4 conscience il voit le bon coup
mais ça te fait chier de jouer c'est
trop compliqué il dit ouais je vais
garder contre le contrôle en juin un
truc un peu plus calmes c'est terrible
ça d'arroser chaque psychologiquement
quand tu sais que c'est le bon coup et
c'est très bizarre de dire je vais pas
le jouer mais en fait en soit
psychologiquement c'est un peu bizarre
même c'est que c'est le bon coup tu es
censé jouer mais je sais qu'on fait tous
pareils on va rester sous contrôle ma
place et s'assurer ouais ben ça t'es pas
sûr à 100% en sus ton intuition te crie
de jouer ça tu aimerais melman je dois
faire qu'au nul ça suffit pour quoi je
vais risqué mais problème c'est qu'à
force de faire ça une fois deux fois
trois fois
toute ma joie des coins for a common
phare - far et et tu glisses
mais le père bah tout cas tout augmente
les chances de perdre ma terrible et
donc ça me faisait penser à ça la partie
d'avant que la grille a pas eu le choix
s'est recomposée de façon c'était fait
cet effet là bas tu es bien obligés
d'attaquer leurs adverses tu vas pas
attendre de te faire taper dessus et un
café calais b 3 ici
mais après ces pièces sont pas forcément
super bien placé en fait de gamme et b3
assez mal mais parce qu'il veut viser
des 5
c'est la pire crise pour y aller et
cassent des autres castes qui vise à
être absolument inintéressant taveri par
ya quoi y'a 4 il ya deux points d'écart
il reste quarante trois minutes on est
d'accord donc le 3 + 1 et encore pas mal
de parties à la priora 38 2 1 plus
simple qu'il reste encore beaucoup de
participants pour se refermer plus
beaucoup de temps dans le match il reste
une heure vingt deux matchs en gros mais
on est à moins de la moitié en termes de
partie parce que les partis sont de plus
en plus rapide ouais donc elles vont
s'enchaîner plus vite en gros en moyenne
et à 24,25 partie par match là on en a
vu 10 11
donc il en reste encore 13 14 ans qui
comme g n le chou se fait pas trop
cavalier de prendre sa place on g4 mais
également peut-être d'euros ce qui le
pousse vers sait si c'est frais c'est en
direction du centre donc une pierre deux
coups les noirs sont mieux ici c'était
plus facile à jouer
en fait on a une faiblesse ses pions des
six parce qu'il est arriérée dire qu'il
a plus de pions pour le défendre dans la
case des 5 justement qui est vraiment
faible problème c'est qu'elles n'ont pas
de pièces à mettre dessus et ils n'ont
pas de pièces qui attaquent le pion la
faiblesse base soit disant faiblesse du
coup et donc bas donc comme nous notre
faiblesse elle est intouchable pour
l'instant moi je serai le point fort
qu'on a donc cédé bias assez active on
contrôle les caser les pièces adverse et
mais en liberté pour les pièces
ouais en plus de pions décisifs défend
très mal en deux fois alors que pour
l'attaqué trois fois ça paraît hélas
donc peut-être tour au 6 août uros être
fâcheux pas histoire d'oublier les tours
ça la planète où un petit plan à base de
cahiers 17 qui est fluide qui réussit ce
qui est des 4 c'est un peu lent ga
plutôt pour attaquer au 4 mai tu peux
aussi partir pour car il ya juste un
gain pour essayer de provoquer le g3 est
5 lione le flou et oui sur hariri chargé
3,5 puis après mais car il ya un chien
qui ça peut être une idée aussi c'est le
même aujourd'hui même je redirai f5 du
coup peut-être partie ranger 4 et 5
maintenant
ouais j'ai pensé à 17 mai j'ai quatre
par étage tu viens kg 4 passes et un
petit tempo quoi mieux mais il est hyper
bien ouais bah après c'est pas gagné
mais ça commence à prendre forme
j'adore l'heure n'est vraiment d'autres
gagnent déjà c'est un pion non c'est
vraiment un régal la position je n'ai
pas envie de le prendre mais bon les
cases noires elles paraissent quand même
assez solide grâce au carré lieu 5 et
c'est un pion et c'est un bon piont
outils coulisses l'ademe va m'arriver du
damage 4 et partout où tu peux faire
rage suite aussi un moment pour te faire
un petit j premier tour j'ai eu cette
envie médailles 22 secondes femmes ouais
mais fait tu arrives à calculer quoi
juste une place bien tes pièces c'est ça
ouais non il joue vraiment bien artemiev
ins le placement de pièces là c'est pas
je suis fan de joueurs femme et s'est
déposée chèque qu'on aime c'est fluide
c'est bien
il ya du sens quand on sait qu ou des
plantes c'est bien j'adore cd bonne
partie a montré à des joueurs amateurs
d'ailleurs ça très pédagogique et très
pédagogique ouais il fait rien
d'exceptionnel en fait juste y placent
bien ces pièces mais c'est déjà beaucoup
d'arrivées à faire des coups qui semble
simple sans se prendre de peaux de
banane linafoot ranger deux petites
filles pour défendre le pian tour aussi
ce niveau mais peut-être les six dessins
qu'après ce que j'espérais s'expliquer
de thaler aussi dans les parties avec
les spectateurs c'est parfois aux échecs
même souvent on n'a pas vraiment de
plans très long là les gens ont
l'impression de là les plans très long
on a beaucoup de mini plan et je ressens
cartels sont énormes en fort c'est qu'il
arrive tellement bien navigué avec
beaucoup de mini plan et à ce ballet par
le plan des six ans à chaque fois qu'on
dit du bien de lui il fait de la merde
aux aveux mais bon il a pas dans
l'ensemble c'est très bien ce qui fait
60 entre la traîne cadre il vaut mieux
pas ça marche parce que c'est une très
bonne partie tu vas pas la gagne au
final mais il a autant dominé pour
autant mais tu as raison en fait les
échecs c'est souvent voir un film une
idée directrice
mais en fait tu peux pas la faire comme
ça quoi et donc tu as plein de mini plan
pour atteindre cet objectif à long terme
à long terme et à on a perdu fait
quelques secondes mais en gros on a un
plan directeur unité au genre de rêve
qu'on n'arrive pas forcément à réaliser
et suivant les coups de l'adversaire ça
va nous ouvrir des petites idées dé
petits plans entre guillemets et c'est
toute cette accumulation de petits
plants qui va servir le grand plan mais
en gros 90% de la partie ça va être plus
dé petits plans et des petites
opportunités plus qu'un grand plan en
réalité je crois que j'ai réduit mes
fans
en gros c'est ça peut faire des fausses
faire des petites missions pour
accomplir un truc qu il attend la
première je prendrais et à sydney à new
york mais normalement normalement la
règle si c'est toi qui jouent en premier
ça va pas 1 à 4 fois tendre fouet quatre
amis l'appât du gang ça va faire nul
tenu par il va peut-être tombé à temps
mais ils alléguaient que leur terrible
il à la guerre en fait j'avais une idée
c'est de faire fou 17 fou d un pouce et
6 x 3 x 4 et us en plus ce qui est des
gueules désolé de tout interrompre fab
c'est que je te vois tu es toi t'as
internet qui a coupé
ouais et j'ai remarqué que moi quand
j'avais des problèmes de connexions
serveurs à thiès comme j'avais souvent
des scarlets peu des conversations qui
se coupaient aussi et du coup il est
probable qu'il ya eu un problème
serveurs sur czech comme parce que toi
ta coupe au même moment que lui a
commencé à avoir des problèmes de
connexion donc sur ans et même pas sa
connexion à lui en fait seul est désolé
d'avoir coupé mais c'était parce que ça
et c'est important de la wii mais
surtout non plus ne marchait pas mon
idée donc c'était l'idée qu'ils veulent
peine de regarder mais saguidiba je
n'avais pas de gilet non mais c'est
terrible et je pense que c'est même pas
sur son internet à lui en plus qui
permet là il a vraiment tout contre lui
le pauvre dort pas il a des coupures
internet
ils lui ont lancé le match alors qu'il
était en train de régler la caméra oui
ils sont dans la gueule quoi et non mais
à quoi que maintenant il a dit la tête
encore des problèmes réseau ah bah je
t'annonce que s'il ya une prime comme ça
pour le bullet s'est garé qui va passer
pas mais ça va mais que risque et ricky
passant je dis tout de suite je suis
assez énervé quoi enfin gérard du mec a
tellement mais l'asse c'est plus de la
chance en fait ces attaques est ce qu'on
va bien mais j'espère bien parce que là
c'est enfin j'aime pas vain je sais que
tu es pareil que moi on aime pas quoi
enfin là il a trop de choses contredit
artemiev c'est pas possible à un moment
donné tu veux pas voir l'horaire le
machin le truc les connexions enfin ok
c'est pas possible
après juste soit ait marche normalement
comme tout le reste il peut lutter
contre 6 en fait tu tapes à internet les
parten minutes aura pas le temps de
jeter coup tu vas perdre à cause du
temps en plus comme dit car le pire
c'est que siguiri gagne il va chanter
après enfin fait oui il est vraiment
insupportable
oui j'aimerais très bien maîtrisé le
match
tout était en contrôle non mais en fait
il a cette image de troll sur internet
ou quoi mais je trouve que c'est un
j'aime pas ça maire de troyes les en
fait je sais pas alors que peu importe
ce qui ne tue pas car chute après le
match ouais t'es tu vas faire chi
trachman mais bon kit bond de ces cartes
mémoires et ce avec les gens m'ont
rappelé sur le jazz c'est quand même
extraordinaire que les matches se jouent
à la connexion c'est pas faux ça fait
plaisir
dormez bien sûr - oui oui non mais c'est
vrai que ces moments-là ce certaine mais
on soit le fait de faire autant de
compétitions qui jouent systématiquement
à la connexion ça fait plaisir
oui non mais le mieux c'était quand même
les olympiades trucks a duré un mois et
c'est à deux matches décisifs qui se
virent la connexion j'étais content
braun la finale double médaille d'or
médaille d'or généralement bon il a fait
6 4
c'est génial la fessée kata j'aime bien
ses classes il enferme les pièces il
menace ou 5 un peu la tour b 1 me le
dire c'est une idée que matraque et
blanc et là il vaut qui repart sur une
tour d un an juste et d'être vu comme
south hook roberts problème si ce n'est
lors il va le faire maintenant
probablement ma main je trouve comme
citrouille chan que guy troll mais je
trouve qu'il ya de l'arrogance dans ces
trolls enfin y'a pas ya ya rarement
d'autocritique et d'autodérision quoi
mais bon après c'est vraiment que dans
un sens quoi je trouve après et je sais
pas je enfin après c'est toujours
difficile de juger mais moi c'est pas le
type d'humour qui me fait vraiment rire
on va dire ça comme ça pas de son ok moi
le côté arrogant gèle pas tellement mais
des fois d'un grand gentil où tu fais
arrogant avant et tu vois oui ou non
mais ça ne rapporte rien d'acquis vois
ça comme une qualité c'est autre chose
mais mais mais juste ce mois ci
personnellement ce gip pour se gaver
comme il veut c'est pas un truc
j'aime bien mais je sens pas arrogant
bienveillant tu vois ce que je veux dire
tarot gants bienveillant russie qui
existe je trouve dommage que tu as droit
de jouer un rôle et voilà puis des fois
tu fais autre chose mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est un truc
après jean ça c'est difficile de juger
on peut pas savoir où il ya une hoxhaj
la tonne marque repère un balèze la
tonne pour tout son arrogance à lui elle
est vraiment assumé en fait ce sera
différent fait sur twitter il fait un
max d'arrogance genre machin tweet m'en
fait que pour ce faire du buzz et que
pour que ça lui rapporte du fric au
final je ne sais jamais gratuite fin de
chasse que je veux dire c'est que tu as
un dessin derrière ses fins bon ok c'est
vrai que cela mais je sais pas non mais
c'est toujours pour revendre ses dvd
pour revendre ces machins enfin tu vois
c'est un dessin pas d es à sienne d espn
un dessin ou un plan
ce qui dessine aussi oui mais bon
alertée bien faire un nom mais après tu
vois c'est comme gisin s'est juste une
impression presque personnelle c'est ce
que je ressens mais ça veut pas du tout
dire que le c'est vrai parce que c'est
les goûts et les couleurs et les gens et
tout ça c'est pas j'ai pas un jugement
j'ai pas fait une thèse que pense guy
quoi c'est une impression que ça me
donne non non plus gérard fougeray vu ma
peur mais elle en fait fin mais c'est
qu'ils sont convaincants sur internet
c'est autre chose tu atteins aronian qui
a un peu dans ce même style dans les
conférences de places squares ou un peu
à rockwell est ok mais tu es sûr à 100%
que c'est fou 28e et du coup j'adore
aronian qui un peu il ya un trait
d'humour à chaque fois oignons doux
c'est ça en fait c'était parce qu'il est
drôle en vrai et que l'autre ne l'est
pas mais aussi que je veux dire à rothen
va pas être le truc cette façon poite je
pense ce sport qu'il faut niveau une
forte tu dois avoir confiance en soi et
et mais être un peu un tueur qu'enfin il
faut mais met donc la réunion c'est sûr
qu'il a confiance ouais mais tu vois que
c'est de la grèce ouais tu vois dans les
gens qu'on connaît bien sûr la chaîne
aronian il ferait penser à un maso je
suis à deux doigts des deux gagnants je
l'écrasé tout après hyper est beau
joueur beau perdant tu vois ce que je
veux dire eux ce serait un peu comme
danser dans le style de mazo quoi ça
fait partie du personnage mais tu sais
que le gars c'est une crème derrière
chose que je veux dire c'est du sang il
est comme ça sur la partie parce qu'il
est chaud parce que mes pas bon pour moi
c'est complètement différent quoi sagem
tu vois ça au contraire moi ça me ça me
ça me plaît ça me fait kiffer eux mais
ça je le ressens pas chez guéri ce
côté-là beau joueur tu vois beau perdant
beau mais bon après tout c'est juste une
histoire de confiance on a besoin de ça
pour se rassurer que je sais pas après
ça vient peut-être du coût d'un complexe
et du coup c'est peut-être pour ça que
ça se ressent comme quelque chose tu
vois après un passage du jouet 6
ouais c'est bien joué si on est à fond
dans la tête
ouais cidal prendre un proche 4 et
fourche à tapas écoute là c'est chaud ça
pleure tous les sens est en prison elle
sait trier avec 9,7 c'est beau c'est
fort voilà c'est du 50-50 et choisissez
importe où vous prends ça marchait pas
ouais c'est terrible à ça joue bien la
fab
mais pour le coup pour coup bien qu'ils
atelier celle là quoi est ce que ça
marche il dit pas bien mais là il se
prend pour nous doit quoi il fait lourd
au volant à temps il ya peut-être 3g 4
d'âme des uns est sûre on apprend f4
d'un lycéen
ah non il est parti comme ça on le roi
qui part c'est un roi du desk
extraordinaire peut arriver mais c'est
quoi tout en gagnant on va c'est cette
des six des sept noms j'en sais rien
mais ça une bonne tête quoi mais bon le
pont de fusée non mais t'as pas tari
gwada double dames assez extraordinaire
le roi j'ai mon temps c'est cette dégage
est sympa la partie à il se fait plaisir
artemiev qui gagne c'est génial al thani
pareil vous avez lu résoudre un problème
qu'il a eue dans l'enfance et qui le
bloc de guy en fait après ce match
complètement différent et j'ai toujours
su quoi il a monté son range en chef
cette même s'écria chef chez ces jeunes
espagnols des seuils des sociétés du
yacht show quoi c'est hot shots et très
heureux quoi un congrès c'est que c'est
bizarre bizarre est quand je vais
croiser en v est gelée pas sorti un
mauvais gars du tout ou plutôt ça va et
ça commis mais ces trucs sur internet ou
quoi c'est ça semble différent c'est
moins - boîte azotés c'est bizarre mais
quand je croise dans l'ascenseur tout
soit toujours un petit mot un petit
match est vrai plutôt plutôt sympa le 15
mai il fera vraiment très sympa après
c'est l'image qu'ils renvoient et pas
après la vague actuelle issue alors
attends tu vas théorique va bon train
non mais tu vas théorise ladoux pas non
votre jeu mairie
alors voilà de la théorie de vlad
pourquoi il se comporte comme ça parce
qu'en fait il est tellement nulle
donc quand même ça des incapables de
gagner une partie d'échecs si on
n'essaye pas de forcer le gain élevé les
autres voilà c'est ça en fait la seule
manière enfin qu'on ait vraiment envie
de te forcer le gain c'est absolument
insupportable
et donc ils le feraient exprès ne serait
pas son vrai caractère et le ferai
exprès pour que j'en ai vraiment envie
de le défense et pour qu'il ait une
chance de gagner
en fait ça bien les nuls jusqu'à très
tard voire dans toutes les théories de
la ddt à détrompe toi il est
complètement nul
après ça c'est vraiment important non
mais la théorie est tellement au dessus
en fait non c'est beau c'est
extraordinaire
sachant qu'il est nul il est obligé
d'être arrogant qu'on veuille le battre
quoi ces petites gênes bien évidemment
table à des vrais motifs et s'est
confirmé pour demain ou pas encore anne
s'est trouvé à redire une photo bien ton
nom mais blain d'après en live il te
sort pas des tel truc parce que c'est
gros c'est pas une source avant d'une
soirée c'est quoi être mon coup mais tu
es très heureux de sortir son truc et
ben c'est pas chouette patron qui se
marrent quoi c'est génial j'ai pas en
live si sortir une telle théorie mais la
tuerie je vais je n'ai jamais dit ça
maintenant je n'ai jamais souscrit à
cette idée des fois il dit ça je n'ai
jamais souscrit à cette idée que j'adore
quand il dit ça j'ai jamais souscrit
quoi jambes ladite parle en fait il fait
les abonnements orange ou sfr
alors on me l'a dit le sort de ces trucs
mais c'est c'est priceless quoi c'est le
boss du game quoi d'autre qu'elle prend
je pensais je
souscrit à cette free sur certains noms
comme freescale
mais je pense à ça pour eux que pour lui
sa veuve la ddt félicien a les cannes
prestige et du coup tu cette envie de
tabac sympathie pour guy après ça j'ai
tout de suite compris a pas trop si je
pense que tu prends g5 comprend pas la
tour qui coulisse et à tout le monde qui
vient vers le roi
on va voir ça marche mais ça a l'air
bien tour 4 comme ça vous choisissiez
sheva bruit dans ce genre et pour les
gens qui connaissent pas vlad essayer de
venir demain normalement il sera là on
n'est jamais sûr avec balade peut pas
être sûr à 100% il sera là demain à 21h
il nous parlera de queens gambeat qu'il
a analysé très sérieusement russe du
coup il a fait une analyse en russe très
excellente jamais pour moi c'est la
meilleure analyse de là la meilleure
analyse échiquéenne de la série
et donc ce sera j'imagine passionnant
donc normalement sera demain à 21h et
forcément il y aura des punchline et il
ya cette tour des uns et le truc trop
bien eu mal pour éviter foulée qu'un
vrai est-ce que ça a commencé ce qu ils
font nul alors je sais juste alta qui
l'a mis 2731 à la série mais vu que pour
vlad les classements lots n'ont pas
vraiment de rapport avec avec les
classements qu'on donne normalement je
sais pas si 2731 est un bon classement
un mauvais classement fait bon souhaite
pas trop mal la série n'est pas terrible
bien comme ça que je les noter qu' qui
est moins de 27 50 incroyable même
navarra est plus fort que ça
game se dire mais je pense qu'il a aimé
mais comme je disais quand on donne et
il me parle d'un restaurant qui n'a pas
trop aimé mais diffusée dans un
classement de 2005 2005 50 jeudi où il
fasse a quand même pas mal
tu rigoles samba demarage quoi oui la
voisine est donc je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire
c'est un fast food chinois qui était à
peine grands maîtres qui l'avaient
guirassy monsieur fils déclare être très
sympa non mais on va manger très sympa
aussi
c'est puis ces trucs sur internet qui
non les blattes je pense qu'il a aimé la
série ma part je n'ai pas parlé mais
d'abord ce que tu m'as dit mais je crois
russie ouais mais m'avoir à main a
qualifié ce qui est intéressant ce qui a
parlé d échec en union soviétique etc
je pense à un sujet intéressant c'est en
a rarement l'occasion de parler à des
gens qui l'ont vécue en réalité quoi de
la terre donc qui est reparti seul
viennoise mais avec g3 cette fois pas eu
tous ces quatre sites intéressants
besson qu'ayant eu quatre tout ça
pouvait si je pense il est bien le fond
b6 aussi les soins de mode est banale et
les villes historiques tour bien qu'elle
attaquera v7 donc c'est une case très
très bien pour le fou défensif et
agressif en même temps est ce qu'on va
faire foulée de ces 4 à 4 sur 7 tentés
de provoquer des traces un enquêteur
flou trop après tu des stellistes être
le fou en b 6 et d'ailleurs il ya maxime
qui m'a dit un truc hyper intéressant
sur la série ouais genre moi j'ai trouvé
que c'était lent et je me suis ennuyée
et en fait maxime à une théorie
fantastique il a dit oui mais c'est
parce qu'en fait comme nous on joue bien
aux échecs tous les passages sur les
échecs en fait sont inintéressants et
mis en fait quand est moins forte
ça te nourris quand même les moments où
ça joue alors que nous des moments où
fait il parle de karo kann de machin a
failli oui fap outil si la nage darfour
coiffa tu connais les noms d'ouverture
tu as envie de dire bara brenn suis en
fait on s'en fout du coup quand tu es
complètement amateur même t'apprends des
noms d'ouverture tu apprends les formats
des tournois jazz le rappel d'un moment
elle joue son premier tournoi ils te
disent oui mais là tu as jour de la tum
h à fin mai en fait nous c'est comme si
je me revois à 7 ans explique éric de
tournois je m'en fous mais mis en fait
quand tu joues pas tu apprends des trucs
en même temps sur le milieu des échecs
et du coup la série elle te paraît moins
lente que quand tu as mais pour le coup
je pense que ça plus plus haut non
joueurs que joueur pour autant sa part
sont dégoûtés tous les joueurs parce que
c'est passé pas si mal sylvia non plus
mais c'est
mais je pense que les non joueurs vont
sûrement plus apprécié ouais mais j'ai
bien aimé ce commentaire de maxime en
fait je trouvais que c'était très
pertinent mais le rythme est poussif
mais mais le truc le classer comme le
rythme et déjà poussif en fait quand tu
rajoutes du poussif au poussif en fait
tu t en zone rouge après c'est trop
poussif
bah en fait ça que moi j'ai un oncle
fille faisait à peu il aura pu en faire
un film d'une heure trente deux heures
mais c'est vrai que tu as moins eu le
temps d'entrer dans les détails
d'expliquer le genre de choses tout seul
tu dois perdre quelque chose ouais t'as
est vrai que j'en parlais que doc phd
série sur la médecine m'a dit qu'il
avait beaucoup de mal à regarder tu as
quelqu'un qui écrit en vrai c'est comme
dr house il était médecin tellab on
avance on diagnostique asvp bah ouais
c'est un peu ça en fait que tu as un peu
cette impression quand tu es joueur
d'échecs mais en gros c'est bien passé
bonne série que s'adresse aux joueurs de
chaque point oui c'est vrai ce grand
public et et bah tant mieux si ça a plu
non mais juste comme le commentaire de
maxime là dessus je les trouvais très
pertinents donc dans une poubelle pour
artemiev qui comme prévu plus la nuit
avance chez lui plus il craque quoi bon
mais je suis candidat gagnant en fait il
avait marqué on dit fou prend 1,6 fc
bruges surfe au profit cf 5 tout le
monde le savait franchissait pour être
un thème sympa pour jouer sur le la
déviation du pion g7
ouais la surcharge alors
qui a aidé deux annoncés juste viande -
est à tapas rien quoi bon après tu
essaies d'arnaqué un peu mais bonne
position pour guider la wii
peut-être retour à deux tours avec ace
et 4 mai pour essayer de bon il est
vraiment moins bien mais c'est encore
foutu peut-être le prendre de ces
bizarres main d'henry 32 ha mais on
commande c'est du gâteau pour passer
quand même mais l'effet est plus malin
avec cast est peut-être plus dur à
gagner tu es du mal à créer l'an passé
maintenant si on a vu le film sur fiche
avec tobey maguire
moi j'ai vu mais j'ai vu il ya longtemps
je débuts en grec je crois j'étais à
athènes dont j'avais vu où on va le
sous-titré ça va même faire casser 4
après et baignera can 92 qui va vivre
encore plus à l'est avec carte bienfaits
de l'eau shanghai ou si c'est pour faire
des saints qui sont à l'est d'ataq est
simple il faut défendre le pion
juste des m17 mans ouais et quoiqu'ils
c4 et b5
car le 3 mai peut-être twelve c'est tout
je peux pas faim alors t'es mis en place
et je te montre la came c'est de pire en
pire quoi c'est hier à peine plus vieux
ou vers quoi tu vois ça well as et ses
impôts ici pays peut il s'endort quoi
séduire surtout qu'ils restent encore
toute la séance après des débuts lettre
c'est loin d'être fini tout ça je trouve
ça un peu dommage
non mais j'espère juste que j'arrive à
pas fermes après le match ça
m'embêterait qu'on ne sait jamais
alors
la différence avec le film de pointe
sacrifices et aux cyclones travail c'est
une histoire vraie il faut bien voir que
l'histoire de netflix est un roman
historique jamais existé vous avez voulu
faire quelque chose qui existe sur une
femme il aurait pris par le gars vous là
il aurait pu faire une histoire vraie
mais ce n'est pas le propos
non non je sais mais géré side avec
voulu faire une histoire avec une femme
qui veut très bien aux échecs ça
existait par là c'est le fait que des
femmes puissent battre des âmes ça c'est
pas fou c'est pas impossible
je fais pas des six faire nul normes et
pleutres mais pourquoi ado qui n'a pas
le choix on fait payer ses 3 700 ours
est parvenu le autrement mais terrible
bagarre vers saclay jeu dans la première
partie du match
sauf que n'ait pas fait des cinq tout de
suite les faits aux 6es des cinq après
auxerre sont une française et le moi
c'est plus plus ce modèle à pin c'est
bizarre qu'il n'ait pas joué à la
précédente mais j'espère tu disais quand
il a le choix en fait entreprendre le
risque de gagner dans une meilleure
position et faire nul il va le faire en
fait il va pas prendre le risque est
bien juste avec paul gart à l'histoire
un extraordinaire quand elle a rencontré
fischer aussi voit la frontière
hongroise et regarde tu pourrais
vraiment faire une série de soutiens
note à ses soeurs de père qui les a
formés
c'est toi tu voir tous qu'ils soient
avec le père aussi mach 1 re s est tu
peux faire vraiment un gars qui aime
vraiment faire une série tu commences
par les parents qui ont des jeunes
enfants il concentrait la première soeur
et puis la deuxième et puis machin de
faire des saisons plus tard m le plus
terrible c'est que même avant il fait à
sa famille la plus ou moins cherché par
la poste sont écrites ou faire une
expérience dans ces terribles en fait
l'histoire tu connais peut-être pas tous
les jeunes y a pas longtemps mais en
fait c'est plus ou moins une expérience
ses fils et fille scientifique
c'est terrible en fait quand tu dis des
trucs dans le sens où en fait ils
croyaient que n'importe quel enfant
pouvait être excellent être génial dans
un domaine si tu l'entraînait et tulle
éduquée de manière correcte lorsqu'il
était petit probablement qu'il a raison
de dire et comme il a pris les échecs
pour lui c'était un moyen de mesures
objectif puisqu'il ya un hello il ya un
classement et ses îles c'est pour ça
qu'il a choisi les échecs mais en fait
du coup le gouvernement indique est
complètement fou donc il a écrit as des
as des institutrices et ou du coup sa
fin je crois qu'elle est ukrainienne
enfin ils ont vraiment fait des enfants
dans l'objectif de faire le pas mais je
peux enfin dans le cadre de leur
recherche scientifique quoi ces extrêmes
à l'histoire générale est juste
extraordinaire ceva on dit je pense que
les gens croirait moins que l'histoire
est vraie comparaison maîtrisé en
victoire
l'histoire est plus où j'en fait ok je
sais pas je voudrais que le psd lui même
joueur pas très forte mais je pensais
que c'est ça le truc mais en tout cas
les trois soeurs étaient fortes
judith bien sûr la plus forte de toutes
a été tournée mondiale fait le pari que
c'est sofia qui était la plus douée qui
était la plus forte mais cet email - les
échecs
ok mais c'est elle qui était la plus
forte mais elle a été championne du
monde
enfin bon l'histoire et ouf après si tu
te documentes faut aussi retiré le vrai
du faux talent de ses six metref f3 oui
après come stay a beaucoup d'articles et
tout ça moi j'ai lu des sur des articles
j'ai pas fait de recherches approfondies
dont il dort ici avoir du sensationnel
et ils ont dû un petit peu en rajouter
mais en soit ce serait intéressant de
faire un film dessus
[Musique]
enfin elle est belle il ya des belles
histoires dans les échecs au moins
intéressante bugs
il ya des trucs à raconter c'est un
crime que l'e3 était aussi doué aussi en
soi parce que je suis à rennes qui était
la moins forte
résister quand même numéro 1 2 3 mondial
allez vous à marcher sur l'éducation
oui ah oui tu peux pas remettre en cause
mais elle parle plus mais je pense qu'il
a raison pas c'est sûr que si tu
spécialiste du spécialiste des enfants
dans un domaine ils seront forts après
ils sont enfin du coup tu vois un gars
comme des différences georges suis dit
c'est juste office mondial à
l'extraordinaire plus jeunes commettre
de l'histoire sont en hip hop du record
de précocité ou quoi et donc qu'elle
était mieux que ses deux autres soeurs
mais qui ont quand même été été fort toi
moi et je crois qu'elle parle cinq ou
six langues aussi ce qu'il reprenait les
langues en parallèle un c'est vraiment
un truc de ouf en fait il y aurait il y
aurait il y aura une belle série à faire
là-dessus intéressante on s'est un peu
égaré mais c'est certainement cette
partie fabre c'est quoi ces gars là non
moi veut pas trouvé le prénom 80 on
avait plus ancien abri de microfinance
soit même le fameux blue blood bowl g7
ouais plusieurs égards pour les normes
ça va ça devrait les noms oui bien sûr
ça leur prend 1,6 ok le max de paul
gâche et pato beast est 8e mondial chez
plus exactement serait cia to set j'ai
vu à part longtemps mais c'est lui tout
s'est tu
mais en fait elle a eu sa première fille
quand elle est à son top aussi important
huitième rang
allez un sas importance particulière
pour le match artemiev figanières prend
deux points
bon bref
pronostic 2 score final pour ce soir du
radiant d'adieu radio savate artemiev
sont plus forts dans ce format en tout
cas mais il ya l'histoire qu'ils soient
en sibérie qui est bientôt quatre heures
du match et les 600 d'or devant sa
souris pourrait lui jouer des tours
donc on serait là un point d'avancé pas
beaucoup donc tout est possible en fait
dans ce match mais là il bouge bien des
pièces il rentre sa seconde rangée il
embête un peu son adversaire
on va voir une partie important je pense
pour la suite du match en tout cas on va
voir normalement ça doit finir par une
nulle mais bon avec si peu de temps ça
peut paraître tous les côtés un
exactement non plus trop le temps de
réfléchir à perdre et il faudrait que la
souris des points de connexion c'est pas
tout peut arriver
à la demie points perdus sur connexion
il fait par linqan tout à l'heure dans
des matchs serrés comme ça mais là il se
crée le pion h passées c'est bien ça
pourra pour les noirs là je pense qu'il
est mieux maintenant ah oui à g iii
pardon désolé fausse alerte donc
bah écoute on va voir sur la paire de 4
3 pouces et un haïtien qui peut arriver
koupreïev 2002 déjà froid bah écoute ce
domaine pour lui gagner
il repasse à plus de hockey il reste 7
minutes à peine donc ça peut être la
dernière ou l'avant-dernière ça dépend
comment ça ça fait partie sera longue
ok tu as eu que des petits systèmes
obtient trois poisons maintenant ouais
pareil où il joue un peu plus forts à
retenir est que plus de et c'est plutôt
lui qui a raté les au cast les problèmes
de connexion qu'il est légèrement
légèrement supérieur après ça veut rien
dire fable 2 points à une demi-heure de
bullet y aura neuf parties ça peut vite
tourner en arrière quand on regardait le
match finalement il a gagné 8,1 duda les
bullet mais une différence de plus cette
donc ça peut vraiment les bullet sont
répartis en une minute donc c'est encore
un jeu un peu différent
c'est un jeu de vagues qui marche un peu
par des vagues quoi tu peux être dans le
bon dans le bon tempo ou inversement et
ça peut vite aller dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
ça serait que moralement sur 100 m si on
perd une bon ton père une soif d'aller
mais tu penseras 3 à 4 c c'est lourd oui
et tu as pas de pause entre les parties
s'enchaînent 700 chaînes dont on a le
temps tête d'aller passer un peu d'eau
voire un café j avoue je souffre c'est
bon allez je me remets ça peut le faire
mais là en fait t'es juste la tête sous
l'eau
ah oui tu es t sous l'eau totalement
général et blanc une nouvelle fois un
tueur à réussir à pousser eux quatre
t'as quand même le centre si un jour tu
fais avec 14,5 c'est fini oui
complètement
datacash cette option là bas ok mais bon
qu'est née casbah peut être faible à
madame ces trois jours ça peut arriver
aussi
ouais mais là c'est sûr que c'est gros
avantage blanc bah je vais bien
introduit de faire de 4 ans levé le
cavalier faire f 4 e 5 puis rouleau
compresseur s'il peut le faire la partie
sera finie fab est ce qu'un caïd des
deux aussi pour revenir vers ses 4 tu
avais kg 5e 6 qui peuvent traîner
parfois pour venir la russie s'est déjà
aux quatre kallio 5 pour bloquer un peu
tout ça quel cadeau qu'une envie de
préparer quatre sépare de son fou pourra
le carrier qui vient contrôler les cases
noires en fait
qui est pour reprendre 5 alors si on
prend à le prendre du plomb peut-être
mais je sais pas si c'est grave ce sera
toujours un peu mais avec ton pions pas
assez dur à bloquer quoi donc je passais
protéger mais aussi prendre l'adami
af459 un f4 il prend de la dame
je voulais prendre du plomb mais du coup
bas il va pas remettre la marche avant
ouais or après qu'est c4 des fois ça
marchera pas tous un bon sens ça marche
takada mais je vais d'ailleurs dès fois
ci ça regardez l'ours est pas un tu peux
pas enchaîner des calices et 4 dames à
trois noms mais même après cela ça sous
pression f4 que faire d'un des quatre
moteurs
bon je branche qui avait 3 et faire vite
et le 5 ou un truc comme ça pour péter
complètement le sens je pense et son
idée damas 3 du j'aime bien l'art à 3
j'aime bien aller essayer de jeu pac man
to man j'aimerais que je pense que tu
fais à 6tu provoque même un
affaiblissement trop peut-être détour b1
et tu switch mighty switch je regarde
combien il reste trois vins auraient
donc ça peut vraiment être la dernière
si la partie va au bout et c'est très
possible ce sera la dernière de cette
cadence
parce que juste exquise on l'a pondu les
restes de 30 et comme ils ont un rajout
à chaque coup ça veut dire un peu sourd
la f5 arrive à faire quoi f3 mais je
pense qu'on aura deux parties tu la vois
pas aller au bout ça là bas au bout du
temps vraiment que ça joue designs ait
n'atteint donc à lit-et-mixe dernière
sur le monde chaque branchement jeu qui
est g5
il faut prendre des cinq way qui
compteront à la case de 6
il est peut-être plus si bien artemiev
ce qu'il a perdu son contrôle du centre
énoncé le fou qui va rayonner sur la
grande diagonale
ça peut tourner un côté à côté
néerlandais
tu sais pas trop quel coup dur 3,5 c'est
logique que s'attaque le pion un peu
plus je pense aussi aux hommes d'abel
cet ouvrage 8% d avoir donc life échec
il couvre les chèques ski à revenir vers
ses trois pour jour les cases noires ce
qui à partir vers a3 ou a4 pour jouer le
pion à quand tout est possible ouais
alors ils peuvent aussi avoir envie de
faire couperont cavaliers et du coup
plus b2 mais f2 mais du coup avec son
coude dames et ça protège latéralement
c'est bien ok donc il veut comprendre
qu'ils ont des six d'ailleurs il a
probablement gagné
tour à tour des six tours sète la tour d
1 à la fin c'est plus vous fait du coup
c'est un vrai pion de plus cela vous met
le roi noir un peu plus faible je vais
faire h4 avec les blanches 4 h 5 6
d'aller créer des trous noirs sont mieux
mais bon
incroyable c'est toujours chiant mais
son avantage c'est qu'il a vachement
plus de temps oui les minutes quasiment
trente cinq secondes va pas repartir en
g3 pour blinder là elle est bien placer
la lame et hk à toi comme tu le
prédisait rendre à 2 ouais mais tu vas
mettre une tour enfin un truc mais c'est
que c'est de nouveau le défaut de guérir
c'est ce qu'en voulant est très en
contrôle il va pas échanger une tour sur
la dame
et puis pour avancer même mois
c'est bien mon cas il veut faire des
dames des six peuvent peut-être enfin il
ya douze jours par les problèmes de
connexion à côté alors tf1 ou de sommeil
qu'il a joué les pions maintenant quel
état il aurait existé bas auquel il va
ces 4 août on va voir
mais revenons géant céderait c'est
complètement foutu le ciss que il fait
des chèques et plus rien plus rien il
est nu mais il va réussir à vous amener
jusqu'en bull est finalement auquel tout
temps mais quand même fait une petite
menace je m'attendais hockey ou quoi
ouais short yves près c'est beau quand
même il se bat bien avec si peu de temps
ils tentent encore s'il aura laissé
échapper tant mieux mais si jabra
coillard d'amasha matin la femme
et sinon il ya des objets vide qui
menace avec un mystique ou quoi il
matait la fesfut sein et à et ça termine
cette section fab du 3 + 1 donc artemiev
qui domine mais qui fait pas on fait le
score finalement non n'est pas de break
avec un point d'écart c'est quand même
et non mais big fish c'est pas le pseudo
de retenir c'est le cph et au jihad au
cf feydeau cia fait qui est tout aussi
fort un blitz aussi très dangereux est
très très bon ils sont excellents les
deux donc il va rester à il va rester
une trentaine de minutes fab dans un
match très très serré assez serré c'est
cool c'est bien bas serait dommage de
suite pouvoir se sert et ça va oui j'ai
eu des hauts des bas dans le niveau de
jeu et bessat avons au moins c'est serré
et il ya du suspense ouais non c'est
cool c'est cool c'est qu'aulas temps je
vais écrire à amazon pour lui dire que
ça va finir un peu avant s'il veut venir
un peu avant après on est con à venir
c'est quoi ce soir on va essayer de
passer 28 58 30 ans je crois il convient
là je suis pas limon qui descend tu sais
jamais vraiment à combiner la riva
regarde le doigt des matchs et de 30,1
doit peut-être même sait pas on sait pas
on ne sait pas donc à temps je lui ai
écrit je vais mettre le bon titre déjà
pour le décollage du capitaine mazet
gens qui sont pris la pub
je vais vers 2850 mètres d'altitude une
montagne à franchir
s'il y arrive ce sens il sera de bonne
humeur toujours en ça répond ici un peu
comme un i télé pas sur la mer message
de mathieu minel d'options gagnante
non j'ai pas vu le message du tout avec
les foules à bath ça donne l'impression
qu'il ya un truc à chercher mais du coup
on a dû enchaîner sur les autres partis
et ne peut le temps de chercher à fond
mais je suis pas étonné que ça puisse
gagner je suis pas vu comment tout cas
beaucoup champion des pays-bas désolé
les gars est chez scam insatiable et 5
mai il passe cinq à quatre on a gagné
sur son émission live avec avec
chapovalov andy murray ne coule mais
l'émission à l'émission de gaël il ya un
débat alors sur le tennis ou djoko qui a
dit qu'il voit pas pourquoi on pourrait
pas jouer les grands chênes en deux sets
gagnants on à dalil dit non non beaucoup
mieux de enfin moi je pense que si je
comme adam vieux je ne juge pas et
peut-être un débat là-dessus près il
pourrait faire en deux sets gagnants
super tie break qui peuvent aussi
trouver des formules mais ouais moi je
suis plutôt pour le 3 set après bah je
sais pas les leçons ils sont assez
chaude hantise pour le crédit lyonnais
tout ce qui peut rendre notre recul en
quatre jeux aussi ça doit y avoir une
idée derrière barry lampard tellement
tous tout le temps qu on saura pas
pourquoi fac qui a été recoupée c'est
terrible
connexion en cours fab en sueur on l'a
perdu 3,7 pour être plus sûre et femmes
uterwedde djoko djoko qui a fait muter
fab
père du fab je vais enlever la capture
d'écran fable c'est là qu'elle tend les
uns
donc attendez un problème avec avec
fabre bon peu importe s'il va revenir je
vais le laisser rappelé je suis pour ça
que sur le téléphone on regarde
on va voir on va voir ce qui se passe
désolé les gars comment je vais bien ça
va ça va titouane je vais très bien
merci
c'est la grande forme du coup la partie
est à l'arrêt non non là c'est juste que
c'est la pause
les parties n'ont pas redémarré à moins
qu'ils aient un bug sur une chaise comme
on va voir on va voir comment ça ça
enchaîne allez on va se lancer pour les
bulles est ensemble
ah les femmes qui va revenir enfin bon
on est en train de te retrouver
on avait perdu quelques secondes mon fab
lalalalalala temps on ne t'entend plus
du tout fab five tu es en train de
sombrer dans les méandres d'internet
la cesse alors de revenir un petit peu
fade en sueur fab au ralenti fabre femme
qui disparaît fable homme que l'on
n'entend plus l'homme comble on veut
faire taire or la tp sur le coup les
amis djokovic djokovic qui est un fab à
ses tarifs à ben c'est terrible on va
voir on va voir ça ça semble pas trop
aller enlever mais ça peut revenir
on ne sait pas
à saint-etienne ils ont la 2g on nous
écrit dans le chatt terrible maison des
jeunes j'ai de plus soit bon alors ce
match et ce qui reprend ou pas fable qui
tombe encore sur minitel terrible
l'armée la salers balle et là ça a l'air
d'aller
alors à temps en temps en temps on
n'entendait pas vraiment parce que
j'avais coupé ton micro aussi du coup
non mais en fait moi je n'entendais pas
de bazas j'ai commencé à 30 ans il ya il
ya 45 secondes 40 soutenu que les lobbys
et de remettre ton son jeu j'ai pas
renié j'épargne et aux gens les les
coupures internet a bien fait du coup
j'avais préféré à couper normes et
c'était c'était quasiment inaudibles les
30 premières secondes c'était terrible
non mais j'imagine non mais du coup et
le ferons quand même de fibres qui est
pas réglé bon orange qui se bougent pas
et donc je suis une chimie en connexion
sur sur le téléphone quoi c'est mieux
que quelques bons tard mais c'est sûr
non mais c'est parce que quand on a
rallumé le téléphone en fait ça à partir
pour les bullet mais en gros tu as eu
ton téléphone qui a dû ouvrir toutes les
applications et ça a pris beaucoup de
connexions
c'est mon vrai que ça marche le salé la
première minute bon alors il a dû du
coup ben quoi c'est chaud on va voir
est-ce que la collection d'art thénia
devait être meilleure que la mienne déjà
c'est un peu la question en tout cas il
part avec la lapine
notre ami fin avec la lapine avec le
truc à 6 mais dans une configuration à
la pine fab epyon isolé ce qui est
plutôt sympa je trouve à jouer en bullet
avec les blancs ça je trouve que c'est
cool parce que tu as plein de
possibilités de sacrifice de partout je
peux faire h4 pour choquer en plus que
tu peut choquer de partout tu peux faire
flamber 1 dames détroit je trouve que le
jeu est plus plus simple
avec les ornements way après un énième
gros spécialistes de la structure donc
il doit avoir de bons réflexes
donc ça devrait le faire
trois kényans des cinq qu'elle est prêt
à reprendre cavaliers comme ça tu
échanges encore les fous étais tu
reprends même du cavalier pour viser au
sein car il me de marge et 6 et tours
détours des huit chiens et après ça
appartient à tour ses huit balles aussi
il peut échanger un métier pas échangé
forcément toutes les tours a fui au
moins garder une mais bon il a réussi à
gérer un passage un peu difficile je
trouve artemiev et là ça stabilise petit
à petit or il est pas mieux mais ça doit
alors est ce qu'ils pensaient en premier
prend se prend et fuite après direct
mais il va revenir à la page et 7
peut-être 0,7 kg
ouais 3d de sa ducati choc
et là il va partir en h4 avec la lame je
pense parce que du coup tu auras des
cavaliers à 4h et roya dame à la rate et
qui quichotte qui du coup même et c'est
bien joué je trouve le damage 4 à [ __ ]
si l'éducation devient savas on revient
c'est pas mal ils sont deux coups pour
coups
fo à 8 et du coup ils alger 3 passes qui
a pas le damage un match auquel assez
les blancs qui sont un peu mieux et
afyon réussissent faible mais bloqué va
désolant et poker alliés mais bon ça
joue un bon niveau tant ils sont tous
pareils une vingtaine de secondes chacun
sa irem faire ça les change qu'elle
défende qui va revenir vers f5 non tours
j'ai appris de mes parents f5 sur votre
peau avec ceux de prendre sa source et
si ce week-end prochain et maintenant
ils accueillent pranger 3 paresse et
jolie dame prend sa rodez de partout et
c'est fait et maintenant c'est le joueur
russe l'un qui prend les devants fab
dans la partie car il y eut atteint 24
adam des cinq bien joué aussi à l'iscae
bouchahda machin mat
ah oui en plus tu mets ton ailleurs
certains
mmm à l'otan avec ces coups là et ils
hériteraient artemiev malgré son le fait
qu'ils doivent dormir il voit vite etc
tactique mais attention c'est show dame
b 3 tours 8
chez tour des trois réunions mais c'est
tellement fou le pion ici ses protégés
de partout et d'amd cinq prises des 4
nom est ok tu en prends des cartes ça
fait mal il ya une grosse force à
prendre l'eau en plus wafa s'est pas
encore fait avec une tour sur la 7e
s'est jamais ce qui peut arriver au
quart de tour des dallages 504 pour et
d'un match 5 un match en match
ok il entend bien y fait nous avons fait
le break ouais il fait le break 2 points
d'avance alors fabre en gros dans cette
cadence là il ya entre 7 8 et 9 partis
suivants commence à jouer mais j'ai
l'impression que les deux hommes jouent
des parties très longs gains depuis le
début donc moi je verrais bien un match
à cette wii party ici ouais donc ça fait
un point ça fait deux points d'avancé on
va dire qu'il reste sept parties si l'on
gagne 3 c'est gagner il doit faire trois
sur trois sur eux sur sept nous fait une
sorte de ruiz alors que dit ou passé
horizon trop fort on sort la remise au
bon moment mais là en plus ses positions
là j'ai l'impression qu'il joue j'ai vu
jouer tellement de fois ces positions là
sur internet j'ai l'impression qu'il est
tellement bon quand il met la petite
pression avec le four b2 les petits f4
qui peuvent traîner les cavaliers ou
quatre qui viennent il obtient une
nouvelle fois sa position le joueur
russe
et là on va dire cette partie la fable
ces salles où il peut vraiment faire mal
passé à plus 3 ça ça pourrait être
décisif
ah ça commence très fort c'est clair
comme ces cartes il joue la petite
finale refusé et là il bloque un peu
hâlé sait plus quoi faire l'addition
ailleurs le hold up à ce titre annonce
qui aura plutôt 8,9 partir bien ce que
je disais à l'instant d'ailleurs mais
oui petit nul toujours deux points
d'avancé pour le joueur russe et guy
fabre qui
on voit un étau de ma roxy face à face à
la structure cinq des six toi tu es un
grand spécialiste de cette structure tu
as écrit un bouquin sur la structure de
plus entre guillemets comment tu l'as
dit elle
pourquoi pas les noirs est un bon
accomplissement de la position c'est
d'avoir échangé le show case noire qui a
permis au vph ou et du coup de sonde
restée faible ou tu le tour la défense
ça va tu as fait avec cinq peut-être
voilà c'est fait pour trouver du jeu
quand du cavalier pour revenir vers des
quatre vous sera posée la question je
sais pas si tu estimes évident il
fallait prendre pied à vtt ou pas
d'adduction c'était jouable au 6 mai ok
on va avoir plus proche afin que soient
tenues pour les blancs stock options
mais c'est pas énorme mais il ya quand
même un potentiel offensif des attaques
sur le roi qui peut qui peut être
intéressant pour les noirs un jour s'ils
ont réussi à s'approcher quoi ouais mais
bon là on sent que les blancs sont
plutôt en contrôle n'as pas ton coeur
des quartiers quand même très bien
l'atterrissage était cachée va te faire
dégager il dégage non mais l'idée en
fait c'est que le cavalier des plans que
d'eux tandis qu'ils soient en d5
problème c'est que dès qu'ils se barrent
carrière dans des 4 donc c'est ça le
truc en fait il arrive à stabiliser avec
les noirs comme ça il en train de se la
gérer artemiev là quand même ils
trouvent le contre je peux être un des
quatre noms ici ou là où prise
moi j'en ai fait des quatre dames c5
c'est bien des cas sociaux sont juifs et
dames c5 direct se laisse le choix
il reprend une viande qu'il actions
isolées mais 15 des cats et du coup cité
échange et reprend 2 dont il prend ses
quatre tape pas le temps de prendre de
la toile et la tour d enlèvement
ouais je pense ça donne
il prend et caïds et 4 maintenant il est
tombé le heat est ce qu'il a mais le jeu
bien dynamique alors haletant il ya nuit
en l'air mais on est tombé 4 et surtout
resserré clamadieu de un petit pot
facile à voir pour l'adversaire mais sa
part du cru et tout raciste ou reprend
3,4 by open nul probablement ouais je
pense tour
cavalières et cavaliers affichent 4 sur
mon hockey même si tu perds un pion dans
l'histoire ça je pense tu le perds pas
inquiets prend pions prend pour des 4 et
5 tours dès 5h six noms d'autres j'ai
cinq acheteurs ah oui mais pas moi je
vais encore me mais en gros je crois
juste et h5 soirée d'hier et qui propose
nul ça accepté et artemiev qui construit
son match un fable mais après guéri qui
est que peut quand même être content que
les parties soient rapides et réussi à
faire des nuls sans perdre trop de temps
quoi sert que là les deux parties elles
ont duré la durée d'une koala quatre
minutes donc il reste encore six parties
pour revenir fab il est encore dedans
que oeuvre mais il est dedans
il n'est pas il est pas en dessous en
bullet qui va jouer avec des mots b2
pour essayer de faire b4 ou autre comme
comme soit grande est vraiment simple en
assez intéressant un fab ya pas besoin
de lever de forbach a du coup toute la
pente pêcheurs il va mettre la paix sur
cinq peut-être il fait le cadre pour
posséder entre il va se refaire le truc
tu penses avec les h4 kf5 pas le faire
je veux faire c'est 5 aussi peut-être
qu'il prend la cola n'a pourquoi pas
d'homme pour envoyer la dame sur koné
après avec ayache 4 j'aime bien ça ne
tombe pas battre sud défend bien leucate
une pression sur le centre tu veux venir
des red sox et envie un jour patrick
choisir fait donc six mois plus tôt sans
bien tu joues à tata mains voila si je
vais à terme avec un carrier qui peut
qui peut jaillir alors il prend des 5
il reprend des cinq grands dauphins
alors à temps et peut-être des kuchis
pas je sais pas où vous avez affaire de
fous qui ont des trois est faible car la
paire de fric et noir sont très bien là
j'aurais pas fait mais en gros comme il
joue souvent ce genre de position je
cale pas confiance à son feeling de plus
combien mais j'aime pas les blancs pas
perdre toutes les options sont ouvertes
ces pubs
alors après
et machins et oui mais il lutta pour pas
perdre quoi fin acs gaynor faut garder
les fous ok les gars tu dois partir
chômage cette longue es6 carenity qui
commence à petit sa petite tambouille la
vieille bâtisse où ils seraient ces
échanges est moche
bon on peut attendre quand surviennent
des quatre nouvelles
il veut mettre la pression sur vous
prend tout reprend qui a aidé 3 et
défend ses 4 je pense un truc comme ça
m'est tombé 1 attendait 4
ok bon admettons bon c'est pas simple
pour le blanc et ses cinq fils et le
pion fairway je pense que le carême est
né va pas le père pète noria de plomber
pas facile hein c'est peut-être le
perdant du jour pineau
oui tu avais une mauvaise et elle ont
ils fait toujours là il a peut-être
vouloir passer à 8 c 4 maintenant c est
nul et quatre n'ont pas encore enfin si
et sur ce qui est prends mes quatre ans
et trois fois il la tient encore faut
qu'ils fassent rire ou prou prendre deux
fois trois fois travail et emploi
mais il veut qu'elle et ses six tours
c'est 4 des 5 et 6-3 le tour c'est 4 des
5 tc saint pie x 3,3 ou b2c logique des
rois f1 qui avait lieu un qui avait lieu
de ea et roy détroit red en stand la
[ __ ] et peuvent maintenir des tout
premiers volets et kerry français 3 qui
arriva il va la tenir mon fab
bon bah ouais ouais et puis c'est pas
une opération pour lui ce que la partie
là le elle aura vraiment fait couler du
temps quoi par rapport aux deux
précédentes
oui fait deux nuls mais je l'aï tenue
rapide l'ate a fait couler quoi il
restait 22 minutes avant 18 ans et qui
fait couler quatre minutes encore donc
c'est nul importante fortune
sa poche c'est megan à shanghai et trois
3 nuls consécutive en plus sincères à
fab surtout que cellule où ça joue quoi
ça va loin et ou alors il a mené sa dame
en g3 c'est pour gêner le développement
du fou et fuite
c'est pour ge energy g6 voilà me gêne
tout le monde quoi ça tu prends un café
kf5 logique ou pas logique logique va en
fait
du coup les blues une meilleure
structure en soi mais tout cas pour
développer ces logiques après tu vas
mettre le fond cette l'otan baissait de
faire ces cinq rock puis pas les en-cas
l'ordre il le fait dans ce temps là
pourquoi pas et ce avec le pion h4 tu
lui dis ouais tu pourquoi tu tues rock
quoi tu joues voiture et mais bon il
veut faire du fou des deux grands rock
foo c3 et de laminé allait là les droits
adam des cas du coup ils empêchent le
développement du phocéen en attaquant le
pion b2 il va falloir réagir côté côté
guiry et une à 6 4 il menaçait 4 elle
assure c'est katie se passe à 6 3 4 sa
version et celle de maria padam prend
des 3 puis à la tour se protéger c'est
trop et je pense se sont ils
c'est hyper compliqué les amis et
peut-être images avec grand roque même
mais là du coup il plutôt club avec les
noirs et les blancs qui sont en galère
pour se développer
oui il fait petit rock quand même moi je
pensais que je partirai pour grand roque
0 kg papillon devant mais j'ai toutes
les pièces par et s'échauffent ah bah si
ce fait est très laid tour des huit
belges seraient pas rassurés 1
c'est intéressant c'est une bonne note
partie là encore c'est compliqué ça se
finit dans peu de temps qui l'a fait roi
chf 8 aces qui peut pas prendre 6 6
la tam qui va la mettre en jeu 5 c'est
ça assure cavani 5 des 6 un peu chiant
robert est du coup quel prix s'il veut
prendre des dangers de la dame qui va
partir vers le [ __ ] cinq personnages
paul kariya fils et un iguane surtout
quand il veut qu'à rallier prend mais
bon dans sa noble geste dame g4 vatan
n'est pas de tourner sept fois sa dame
des cinq défend les cases peut-être qui
est dit ici c'est peut-être j'ai alors
dit dans ses sets gagnants mais bon ça
c'est invisible qui a aidé 16h52 tempo
ok mais quand il revient assez discret
chaussée du 4 peut-être ça va aller dans
tous les sens la tempête qui agite à
l'étranger 5 nomades attaque à fond
ben oui mais en tout cas il veut il veut
il veut toucher lui il faut prendre
trois ratés allez c'est pas encore gagné
pour autant et ils m'ont plutôt à la
donne mais ça c'est sûrement la partie
décisive n'était pas loin de diriger la
3.6 commence
il a mis les barbelés artemiev barbu
l'aide mais bon marvelettes de chez
marvel alain complètement terrible ça
fait plus 3 artemiev qui va filer vers
les quarts fermera du valvert magnus
carlsen fab vers l'ogre norvégien contre
qui il devra largement élevé son niveau
de jeu s'il veut avoir la moindre chance
d'avoir dormir voir ceux des phases et
tout ça en tout cas
en tout cas c'est pas encore on l'envoie
déjà en quarts mais c'est pas tout à
fait finie mais reste en ont la chance
là dans les bureaux mais un peu moins
fort
un tout petit peu vrai pas de loin mais
un poil moins fort et guigui en sueur
aller s'ils gagnent ça l'a guéri il peut
il est sous la fin de match virevoltante
guérissent sans mal ouais non ils
arrivèrent les deux joueurs ont l'air
très concentré d'info ce qu'on n'oublie
pas femme qu'il a il a un point qui ont
été mangés à la connexion donc c'est ça
pourrait être +4 ou +5 déjà souvent ce
qui se serait passé dans cette partie où
ils avaient l'avantagé c'est vrai qu'il
a réussi à se remobiliser après cette
défaite sur des connexions il a pas
tilté une seule seconde
c'est quand même tenir le résultat le
directeur d'après centration autres ta
lucidité j'aurais bien et c'est
important ça c'est vraiment pas tous les
joueurs n'y arrive à danser speechless
quand ils ont des prêts à une technique
ou quoi c'est un cartésien fils a pas
bronché
il y apparaissait dans la lande c'est
rageant mais en fait ça c'est cette
mentalité de champion c'est qu'en fait
les trucs extérieur à toi tu peux pas
les contrôler c'est la vie et en fait
comprendre ce que tu sais faire à ce que
tu peux faire et mais c'est très bien
comme ça c'est facile à dire ce que je
raconte mes mais c'est ça la bonne
mentalité annoncé c'est bien ce qu'il a
fait et dans cette partie les deux
nouveaux un peu resserré mais solide
guiry va devoir prendre des risques
maintenant il peut plus permettre de
gérer le match de gérer les positions et
de prendre des nuls là vraiment chaque
nul maintenant rapproche à joindre un
tout petit peu vrai le joueur russe
d'écart mais c'est bien solide pour les
drapeaux les guérit va vraiment falloir
qu'il presse
bailly desai enfin il veut faire flasher
6 échanger son mauvais fou peut-être fin
je pensais ça son plan il a mis la
pression elle d'arriver c'est de rentrer
un moment c'est pas mal mais donc
c'était pas mal a ajouté me fait ce
qu'il fait il crée une incertitude est
allé droit il en train d'ouvrir un peu
le jeu là bas comment ce destin diana
et donc ouais dirait ton re sera
peut-être jamais tranquille oui puis
surtout que au delà de gagner par échec
et mat
tu peux aussi vouloir juste chercher une
répétition de coûts et un nul un côté à
côte artemiev bonne contre affaiblir le
roi dans ce genre de position peut aussi
permettre de très chaud à 4 attendue
pour g5 varetz on va tout faire pour
pour celui pied mais les musiciens
passage du roi aussi peut-être pour la
finale proposant près du cap tout ça
joue très bien côté guy rien très
technique le mauvais goût qui est bloqué
par ses propres pions et donc c'est ça
qui fait la différence pour l'instant
mais bon il s'active via des mines est
fort proche 4 marché peut-être pas ouais
ça va être tendu est ce que le pion à
trois fils adam et à leroy qui
s'activent doit gagner sa guérite où est
roi elle fera c'est bien joué c'est fait
il va aller cueillir le pion m
ça va pas le faire pour google wave
c'est impressionnant la ce qui vient de
faire artemiev quand même parce qu'un
pion comme ça à charger et fab ce
précieux mais il perd le cavaly le il
perd le fou il a raté j'ai 5 mai à temps
il va pouvoir aller tirer la nulle
peut-être pas ce qui va faire payer 5
qui a rallié prend à ya pas qu'à laisser
5 qui avait lieu le 6 mai les terrils
fossard comme un cavalier de masquer ses
quatre alors avec open le cavalier les
amis ne mate pas quatre propositions nul
alors là je peux te dire
il a de la chance guiry de jouer contre
un mec fair-play parce qu'il y en a qui
aurait fait tourner les coups et fait
tourner la pendule mais artemiev qui
défend une nouvelle fois fabre une
finale compliqué et plus de 10 minutes à
jouer
donc là il doit rester une deux trois
quatre 4 parties rs4 partie 3 par la
case ih mangani mathématiquement d'asie
victoire encore il va faire du parti
mais très fair-play artemiev 1
franchement belge aux échecs
ouais il se préoccupe pas de 2,5 ou
faire tourner la pendule si c'est nul c
nul ils la jouent pas plus longtemps et
a souligné fabien ils ne font pas tous
non c'est clair il aurait plus gratteur
je sais pas s'il aurait réussi à jouer
50 couples que c'était pas simple qui
aurait échangé les cavaliers mais il
aurait pu peut-être joué une quinzaine
une vingtaine d'internautes hughan une
minute à la pendule sourire sur le
compte du match quoi elles ne font pas
tous parce que en fait oui le format qui
a dans ce tournoi là ça pour moi très
rare aux américains ont joué quasiment
jamais en fait en partant du mythe est
comme ça c'est en nombre de participants
cependant d'une large donc pas fait
sucer qui a douze parties bomba que tu
fasses nul en 150 tout en 4e nul alors
que la com il ya un temps au bout d'une
heure c'est une pause au bout de machin
avec laon ces cases 12 minutes de match
nous disent faire pendant des ébats il
pourrait avoir envie tu as exprès de
faire traîner de jouer la montre il
s'arrêter le sucre sert à rien aux
échecs passés
donc là il les joue réglo comme si de
rien n'était oui il ajou réglo il mais
il met à mal guérie une nouvelle fois en
bonne position pour lui c'est une balle
de match on peut le dire fabi s'ils s'y
prend quatre points d'écart
il restera trois parties derrière ce
sera terminé donc c'est une vraie balle
de match c'est la première réelle balle
de match
et on va voir si artemiev réussi à la
faire face et fier parce qu'il allait
bien avec un beau camion c5 peut faire
des trois est pris ce carton aussi sinon
ce que touche et c'est peut-être un
expert j'avais oublié à cinq personnes
d'accord je pensais me récupérer l'épave
je n'ai pas vu le 4 j'avais pensé à
cannes mais moi je voulais prendre 4 au
début en fait voiture il a vu le truc
qu'on a vu en fait il a mélangé quoi lui
de tout venant et un truc sur deux donc
tu qu à nous deux on est un artemiev
voilà c'est bien joué sous ses trois
fous là il va récupérer des quatre et c5
voit ses protégés il attaque la ffu des
quatre menaces cavaliers f2 annoncé un
excellent joueur vraiment impressionnant
et guy riffé effet c'est fait son match
en bulles atteint de son côté en fait
griffi oies sauvages ou s'il est
derrière en fait pas si loin dans
l'équipe est en forme mais c'est pas
vrai je criais et là il va perdre la
calloc'h ouais mais c'est fini il
abandonne assez malins ils abandonnent
pour se dire il ya peut-être encore 4
games n'en lier à 3 parce que in game
ces trois minutes 3 4 4 dans la
troisième
c'est fini fab moins fort impressionnant
le joueur sibérien fab
alors est ce que tu penses qui pourra
poser des problèmes aux champions du
monde magnus carlsen ans en quart de
finale c'est un peu la question qu'on a
tous envie de te poser et que je te pose
moi parce que c'est moi qui suis au
téléphone avec toi avec vous il a essayé
ça ne sera pas favori mais norbert as un
beau match
je pense malheureusement pour lui que
non mais voilà pour la réponse courte
quoi bart eeckhout fall essayer de se
mouiller un peu le truc sur fait c'est
que justement artemiev il instille
positionnait l'excellent carlson
c'est plus qu'excellents passe à la
perfection on va dire dans ce style est
donc jason créé le clash même style avec
un mec un peu le fort que l'autre tu
penses tu t'attends un gros score où tu
penses qu artemiev pourra quand même
faire non il va pas sur carton à mon
avis mais problème quand est moins fort
et que tu fous quatre heures d'affilée
contre quelqu'un à un moment il y aurait
une différence
il n'y a pas le clash des styles où
justement toi comme talbot binic ou quoi
balayer tout envoyer qui peut
déstabiliser l'autre quoi en lui faisant
que des recomposée allez je t'attaque
lasser voilà donc tu donnes quasiment
aucune chance artemiev wanna do d'assaut
car je te parle un peu des quarts de
finale pour le tu nous dises un peu tes
protège mes sauts jeunesse au bon déjà
une fabrique de base et tout âge façon
qui soit au top de sa forme
c'était pas mal at il affirmé bref si
saku naka fedoseyev donc bon bah écoutes
je m n'a qu'à mais là pour le coup c'est
un débat sur lequel j'ai peut-être plus
de doute bizarrement à la surprise
générale et mvl contrairement tu seras
pour mv elle sera une soutien sont
annoncés pour ce match et je vais faire
de travers la chaîne info il sait
moulian contemporain mais ouais voilà
écoute on verra wen a cassé je suis
intrigué bon nakad votre île malgré toi
mais méfaits de ces êtres écoute il nous
a surpris
am il a impressionné quand j'ai su qu'il
avait besoin d'accords match amical ce
matin c'est déjà quelque chose donc qui
s'annonce
c'est vrai ce serait sympa c'est un
match donc match sympathique un temps
pensé saturé il faut h trois façons en
plus dire ils seraient obligés de gagner
pour guy obligé de gagner en plus donc
c'est compliqué j'avais pour sa tête
avec les blancs ils allaient jouer
différemment et psystar pranger cinq
fois aussi il s'est fait comme ça ça va
suffire menacé un petit matin
sympathique et surfe où pranger ici ça
évidemment tanger cet étranger ici sa
peau acier de suite champion me faire
tourner le système d'échangé tout apple
800 g 6 faut lui tenir jouer bon ben
c'est simple j'ai pas ce qui est
terrible c'est vrai que si tu rentres
dans le tour fou contre fout ça attire
reprendre encore tellement de temps par
rapport à la situation de match c'est
horrible elle s'arrête d'emory deux ans
parce qu'en fait tu es petit tu crois
que tu vas faire faire d'annoncé face à
monségur
en fait ce que j'avais compris problème
c'est que tu vas pas jetons roi henri iv
il ya des 3 reprend autour des tours d
échec le fou ouais ça son idée chez jean
mais là il va très bien joué avec le
retour du front + 5 bombes à la messe
est dite
ouais c'est finalement mais malgré ça
pourrait faire ça pourrait faire un
point d'un demi point à un point de plus
d'écart enfin un point ou deux points de
plus d'écart avec avec les problèmes
techniques artemiev qui a vraiment été
légèrement au dessus tout non en fait
c'est pas énorme
c'est une petite pression tout le long
et match qui s'est décantée à la fin mai
mais on peut dire sur le global marc
thévenet qui mérite la victoire
oui oui je pense sociaux comme prévu il
était plus fort il se retrouvera en
quarts de finale cette beau match on a
un super plateau quand je sens qu'il
manque personne en fait dans ses quatre
finales après et manque de toi on sait
pas pourquoi je ne sais pas
dimanche note fab libye nous manque
évidemment celle qui est à deux doigts
de participer non joue à rien c'était
genre à rien baki mais ba qui aurait tué
le suspense de la compétition donc
logiquement décline et du cou et du coup
on retrouve ses joueurs n'aura que
maxime qui nous représentera quelque
part et aronian donc on aura un joueur
en 2000 à coup sûr un bâtiment qui sait
moulian ice émollient peut théoriquement
sortir le grand jeu
aïe c'est mouiller on veut faire très
mal attention je n'arrête pas trop les
dates de quart de finale c'est normal
personne ne sait vraiment plus mais je
savais un peu par jeu
j'ai toujours pas compris pourquoi on
sait ben j'ai toujours dit maza de
douane ils tombent
donc maso attentes voire symétrie du
coup il reste une minute 32 matchs trois
et ils veulent mater voulait faire un
être qui a trait sur la fin donc le
temps de sécher texan aura moins ils
s'échappent des repas que 80 s'est il
fait ça a l'air tellement fort les
échappe à la de roi en fait quand à plus
de temps jr quand il a fait duda et
futuna
toutefois aujourd'hui on sait y monte
enfin qu'est ce qu'il fait et puis en
fait je viens de matter qu'on va faire
prépare toi quoi
non mais le problème en fait c'est qu'il
est hyper actif laurent puis quand tu es
tu as pu le tenter de faire échec
en plus c'est un très mauvais réflexe
parce que du coup il se barre il s'en
fout il faudrait arriver à choper les
caisses de fuite avant que les chefs
d'état tellement pas le temps de
campanie oui je fais des footings
balleroy trop fort pour moi que trop
bien pourquoi c'est génial sa troisième
partie en deux jours c'est bon quoi
seconde alors faire le petit plan a calé
deux dames c'est 2 6 3 c'est un anti
casseurs fait le recruter pour les
s'abattent à la base est pas pour rien
qu'on vous dit que c'est un joueur qu'on
aimait beaucoup un fab ya quand même des
raisons il ya qu'il a quand même
plusieurs facteurs qui font que c'est un
joueur très appréciable quand on a un
peu supporters d'un joueur c'est quand
même qu'il a des faits d'armes
intéressant il va tellement s'endormir
après je pense qu'il va y va s'écrouler
après je pense qui clignent des yeux
c'est pas que la fatigue à natick je
pense aussi mais les cernes par contre
c'est sévère ouais ça c'est pas un titre
il a une tête là c'est impressionnant
walking dead
dans le roi le roi vraiment est
impressionnant une nouvelle fois ce soir
elodie cause des vidéos sur les montées
droite fêté leur a tout le temps fait
qu'on arrête de ne pas monter les rois
on va faire les nouveaux répertoires
facile de 4 5 k et ses droits et ses six
f4 puis on prend des cadres d'un match
4e de serre à partir de gotham chasse
par contre ah bon ouais bon c'est pas
mon chalet liszt en fait un bon goûter
de chasse étaient calmes stini soi même
mais après ça ni thierry gotham pièce
qui a fermé les paires combat on peut
plus faire jouer sa 2e année c'est fou
de faire je voulais celle du débutant
quand même cher le faire sérieusement là
tu te rendes mais voyez vous seriez fou
oui mais genre le faire sérieusement
c'est fou mais il trouve quoi de bien
sympa souhaites tu as le centre tu
d'accord mais non boussemart et puis ça
fera un clin d'oeil aux partis qu'on a
vu là on les trois c'est toujours mais
niveau car dès le deuxième coup c'est la
mesure est anti fragile tout à fait oui
mais c'est complètement mon petit
fragilité quand tout va bien faut pas le
faire mais quand tout s'écroule tout
d'un coup ça s'apprend puissance comme
en valeur si vous vous demain à huit
mois vous avez de quoi
il convient de staps l'inde c'est à
plein de valeurs anti fragile et qu'il
ya un vaccin qui marche tant sur la base
il faut aussi aborder des valeurs
fragiles et talât il d'autres 94%
on est bientôt 200 % je pense c'est le
vaccin sanofi
ouais je crois je te dise et 94 points
je peux quoi point 5.6 petrosyan ouais
ouais famose au parti ait eu des dons ça
te calmes fermé mais qu'est ce que je
vais dire ouais sont des bonnes
nouvelles
bah disons oui c'est mieux qu'à l'époque
où on se dit ah rien n'y a rien derrière
un prêt je sais pas quel point ça marche
vraiment ce qui se passe mais c'est
mieux d'entendre ça que non mais là ça
sent bon la plus rien non mais là ça
sent bon ça sent les vacances d'été 2021
avec la lambada tout ça en ligue 2 ça
sent les grosses arrivées au lit toute
sa gratitude pour finir mon fab four est
patron va pas traîner en fait je veux
faire le switch rapidement olivier une à
3-3 au port est supérieur à perdre et
des gens quoi donc du coup merci la
montre et on se retrouve très très
bientôt de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
on se retrouve à 10 h suite dans le chat
et on va on va récupérer je répondre à
quelques questions si vous en aviez on
va surtout aller récupérer seb a
on va aller récupérer cette mazet d'ici
quelques secondes
merci encore fas d'avoir été en ma
compagnie pour ce speech est une tête et
porte bonheur quand même tu nous a
offert de beaux matchs jusque là pour
les beaux matches donc merci pour ça et
on se retrouve
disons dans quelques secondes avec leur
aide merci